la séance est ouverte
donc l'ordre du jour appelle les
questions au Gouvernement et la première
question va être posée par Monsieur
Eric Coquerel pour le groupe la France
insoumise
cette question s'adresse à madame la
Première ministre à propos du budget
dont nous débattons avec sérieux depuis
10 jours vous avez annoncé dimanche dans
un journal télévisé le recours au 49-3
vous y estimiez aussi qu'il minorité de
grévistes ne pouvait imposer ses vues un
accord soi-disant majoritaire je
m'oppose à ce point de vue sur le
conflit en cours mais pourquoi ne pas
vous appliquer cette logique à vous-même
c'est à dire un gouvernement minoritaire
qui censure des amendements adoptés par
une majorité de l'Assemblée pour imposer
un budget antisocial via le 49-3 vous
avez consulté lundi les présidents de
groupe de la majorité puis certains de
l'opposition en
ignorant d'autres quel indécence de
demander un ciel opposition de légitimer
le recours au 49-3 et en laissant en
plus de côté d'autres groupes comment y
voir autre chose qu'une triste mais
veine tentative de marchandage là où
cela doit se discuter c'est à
l'Assemblée nationale
c'est sous le regard de nos concitoyens
il ne s'y trompe d'ailleurs pas un
sondage à test que les deux tiers
d'entre eux sont contre cet usage du
49-3 ils ne veulent pas que la taxe sur
les super dividendes que le reste à
charge en EHPAD majoritairement adopté
par les députés soit arbitrairement
effacés et en plus en catimini je vous
demande donc solennellement madame
première ministre de ne pas recourir à
cet article autoritaire de la
constitution de la 5ème République c'est
la marque d'un régime en crise c'est
pour un gouvernement faire preuve
d'autoritarisme et avouer sa faiblesse
privée ainsi l'assemblée du droit
d'exercer la souveraineté populaire par
le vote c'est déroger à une règle
précieuse et fragile celle au fond de la
démocratie ma question est donc la
suivante pouvez-vous nous affirmer que
vous allez abandonner ce funeste projet
allait jusqu'au bout du débat mettre au
vote un budget mais profondément modifié
par les parlementaires en un mot allez
vous respecter l'Assemblée nationale
sans la brutaliser par un coup de force
de minoritaire merci beaucoup la parole
est à Monsieur Bruno Le Maire ministre
de l'économie des finances et de la
souveraineté industrielle et numérique
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le
Président concret
nous avons depuis une semaine
un débat de qualité sur le texte le plus
important que nous ayons à voter celui
qui engage les finances publiques de la
France pour 2023
je tiens à vous en remercier
personnellement monsieur le Président
Coquerel qui a comme président de la
commission des finances vous avez
participé à la sérénité de ces débats
je tiens à remercier le rapporteur
général du budget Jean-René Cazeneuve
qui a fait un travail exceptionnel
depuis plusieurs jours pour garantir la
qualité de ses débats je tiens à
remercier la majorité et je tiens à
remercier tous les parlementaires de
tous les groupes sur ces bancs qui ont
participé à la qualité de ses débats
ces débats nous allons les poursuivre
ils sont de qualité ils sont nécessaires
sur tous les sujets que vous avez
indiqués et nous permettront d'adopter à
la fin un budget qui sera un budget de
protection pour les Français un budget
qui leur garantit la protection contre
l'inflation contre la vie chère contre
l'augmentation des prix du gaz contre
l'augmentation des prix de l'électricité
un budget qui garantit la
réindustrialisation de la France un
budget qui garantit le bon
fonctionnement des services publics un
budget qui est équilibré à la hauteur
des ambitions de cette majorité de
concilier protection et rétablissement
des finances publiques
et puis il viendra un temps
qui sera celui de la décision et la
majorité
car nous sommes et vous êtes la seule
majorité légitime
dans la nation française celle qui a été
choisie par le peuple français mesdames
et messieurs de la majorité
la majorité prendra sa responsabilité et
les minorités celles qui sont dans
l'opposition prendront également les
leurs pour que au bout du compte la
France est un budget pour 2023 mais dans
le fond ce que vous comptez monsieur
Coquerel c'est que nous ne sommes pas
encore dans la Sixième République nous
sommes dans la Cinquième République et
dans la 5ème république l'exécutif et le
gouvernement prennent les décisions
merci monsieur le ministre
[Applaudissements]
la parole
est au président Mattéi pour le groupe
modem
merci madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre à l'heure où je vous
parle 30% des stations services sont à
sec je sais votre application
personnelle depuis plusieurs semaines
pour sortir de ce conflit qui pénalise
l'ensemble des Français à la ville comme
à la campagne encore ce matin c'est une
infirmière qui n'a pas pu aller
prodiguer des soins très attendus par
ses patients c'est un agriculteur qui
est à court de gazole pour faire ses
travaux d'automne c'est un salarié qui
habitait en milieu rural n'a pu
rejoindre son entreprise pour autant les
négociations ont eu lieu entre les
entreprises concernées et les syndicats
certains d'ailleurs ont estimé que les
résultats obtenus étaient satisfaisants
et d'autres blocs encore comme chez
Total malgré un accord majoritaire
quelque part c'est prendre la France et
les Français en otage
comment imaginer que dans une démocratie
une centaine de personnes arrivent ainsi
à bloquer une partie du pays
l'équilibre l'équilibre de notre société
est fragile nous avons besoin
d'apaisement et nous apportons
aujourd'hui les meilleures réponses
possibles le taux d'inflation en France
est le plus bas en Europe l'État a
protégé le pouvoir d'achat depuis 2020
et les Français le savent en revanche ce
que les Français ne comprennent pas
c'est lorsque les résultats de leur
entreprise parfois importants ne sont
pas réparties justement et ne
bénéficient pas aussi aux salariés
madame la Première ministre vous avez eu
le courage de prendre un certain nombre
de réquisitions il faut maintenant
montrer aux Français que nous les
entendons pour sortir de ce conflit au
plus vite pour rendre à chacun de ce
droit fondamental qui est celui de se
déplacer également pour le rassurer que
ce pays gardera toujours comme boussole
la justice sociale qui assure la
cohésion de notre société et la
préservation de nos talents je vous
remercie
merci beaucoup
la parole est à madame la Première
ministre
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le
Président Mattei
je mesure pleinement je mesure
pleinement les difficultés de millions
de Français qui aujourd'hui encore sont
pénalisés par le mouvement de grève dans
les dépôts pétroliers et les raffineries
vous l'avez dit ce sont des Françaises
et des Français qui ont besoin de leur
véhicule pour se rendre au travail pour
leur quotidien ce sont des personnes
âgées qui craignent de ne pas avoir la
visite d'un infirmier ou d'une aide à
domicile ce sont aussi des familles qui
s'inquiètent à quelques jours des congés
de la Toussaint depuis plusieurs
semaines en lien avec le président de la
République le Gouvernement est
pleinement mobilisé et je veille
personnellement à l'implication de tous
les services de l'État dans la cellule
interministérielle de crise que je
réunis quotidiennement et dès les
premiers jours du conflit nous avons agi
nous avons libéré les stocks
stratégiques de l'État nous avons
augmenté les importations nous avons
permis l'ouverture des dépôts et les
livraisons pendant le weekend
mais nous le savons cette situation
génère beaucoup d'inquiétudes et
l'augmentation des livraisons avec un
doublement dans certaines régions ne
permet pas de pallier l'augmentation de
la demande liée à cette inquiétude il
est donc indispensable de sortir de ce
conflit social et je suis intervenu
personnellement pour que le dialogue
social est lieu chez Total et chez SOS
dans ces deux entreprises dans ces deux
entreprises les négociations salariales
ont débouché sur la signature d'accord
par des syndicats représentant la
majorité des salariés dès lors il n'est
pas acceptable qu'une minorité continue
à bloquer le pays et il est temps que le
travail reprenne
c'est pourquoi en responsabilité j'ai
demandé au préfet de réquisitionner les
salariés nécessaires au fonctionnement
de certains des beaux grâce
à la sortie du conflit chez So grâce à
l'ensemble des mesures que nous avons
prises nous connaissons aujourd'hui une
amélioration sensible de la situation au
plan national moins de 25% des stations
services étaient en rupture à midi
contre 30% le week-end dernier dans les
hauts de France le nombre de stations en
rupture est passé de 55% à 18,5% ce
matin en Île-de-France les produits
pétroliers arrivent de nouveau nous
devons relever le défi de la logistique
et je peux vous assurer que les services
de l'État sont mobilisés pour appuyer
ces organisations et dans cette région
le nombre de stations services en
rupture a baissé de quatre points depuis
hier et je voudrais saluer
particulièrement les transporteurs
routiers qui sont pleinement engagés en
Île-de-France pour nous aider à sortir
de cette situation difficile et je pour
terminer avec le déblocage du dépôt de
nous devrions avoir une amélioration
sensible en ouvrant une Rhône-Alpes
mesdames et messieurs je sais que la
situation est encore loin d'être
satisfaisante pour beaucoup de Français
et que des disparités fortes existent
entre les territoires j'appelle de
nouveau les salariés grévistes en
responsabilité à reprendre le travail
pour notre part nous allons continuer à
agir continuer à intervenir sur les
points de blocage les services de l'État
seront mobilisés jusqu'à un retour à une
situation normale
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Jean-Paul Lecoq pour le groupe
GDR merci madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre 9 milliards d'euros
pour les actionnaires de Total en 2021
son PDG augmente son salaire de 52% et
pour ces salariés partagez-vous les
miettes alors d'où vient la violence
selon le gouvernement elle viendrait des
salariés qui exigent pourtant seulement
de pouvoir vivre de leur travail ce
combat engagé chez Total Lubrizol la
cime et dans tous les services publics
et par tout ailleurs et légitime ça
suffit de soutenir la violence patronale
en accusant les salariés de défendre
leurs droits de mener une grève
illégitime selon vous votre camp est
celui des privilégiés votre méthode
c'est la réquisition la matraque le 49.3
pour ceux qui refusent de vous suivre
vous méprisez le peuple vous n'avez que
faire des conditions de vie des gens
votre seul conseil un col roulé pour
l'hiver jamais on aurait cru entendre un
tel niveau d'indemnité et de mépris
surtout quand on sait que 157 milliards
d'euros d'argent public par an sont
consacrés aux aides aux entreprises qui
pour une grande part vont directement
dans les poches des actionnaires c'est
plus que les budgets de l'éducation de
la santé de l'environnement réuni vous
refusez la conditionnalité des aides
publiques même par l'impôt Vous refusez
une réelle solidarité nationale
ruissellement loi du marché pour réguler
l'économie plus personne n'y croit mais
ça reste votre dogme vous attaquez le
droit de grève et vous refusez
d'utiliser les leviers politiques pour
seulement maintenir le pouvoir d'achat
comme l'augmentation du SMIC
l'augmentation du point d'indice des
agents publics l'augmentation des
pensions et des minima sociaux seuls ces
leviers sont capables de répondre
efficacement à l'urgence de la situation
notre économie en a largement les moyens
les centaines de milliers de personnes
qui sont dans la rue et ces centaines de
milliers voire ces millions qui les
soutiennent exigent des actes
je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Olivier du
socle ministre du travail et du plein
emploi
et de l'insertion
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
de coq vous demandez des actes les actes
sont là les axes sont là dès le mois de
juillet le Parlement a voté une loi qui
soutient le pouvoir d'achat avec à la
fois des aides pour les ménages les plus
fragiles mais aussi la facilitation tous
les dispositifs d'intéressement la
facilitation des dispositifs de partage
de la valeur la possibilité d'accorder
aux salariés dans toutes les entreprises
qui le peuvent des primes de partage de
la valeur déprimé exceptionnelle de
pouvoir d'achat c'est aussi cette
majorité qui a veillait anticiper sur la
revalorisation des minima sociaux comme
des retraites pour protéger le pouvoir
d'achat des Français cette majorité qui
veille aussi est-ce que chaque branche
par branche dans le respect du dialogue
social les négociations soient ouvertes
pour faire en sorte que les minimas
conventionnels soient systématiquement
au dessus du SMIC et que l'ensemble des
niveaux de rémunération fixés par les
conventions collectives soit aussi
réactualiser nous menons des politiques
et des actions qui permettent de
répondre à la question du pouvoir
d'achat à la fois par le blocage des
prix et son et tourne que nous faisons
sur la question des carburants ou de
l'énergie nous le faisons avec des
dispositifs de partage de valeur
d'octroi de prime d'accompagnement des
salariés nous le faisons par la
revalorisation de revenus sociaux qui
sont fondamentaux vous le savez pour
permettre de maintenir le pouvoir
d'achat de celles et ceux qui sont
concernés derrière chacune de ces
actions il y a une volonté politique
c'est celle de la majorité du
gouvernement derrière chacune de ces
actions il y a le respect du cadre légal
et madame la Première ministre l'a dit
chacune des réquisitions qui a été menée
et proportionnée par ailleurs été validé
par la justice la différence entre le
discours permettez-moi l'expression un
peu caricatural que vous avez tenu dans
votre question est-ce que nous faisons
ça s'appelle l'efficacité mais ça
s'appelle le réalisme
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
la parole est à Madame Michel perron
pour le groupe Renaissance
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à Madame Charlotte cobel
secrétaire d'État chargé de l'enfance
madame la ministre c'est choqué et
indigné que nous avons découvert hier le
reportage avant-hier le reportage
diffusé sur M6 dans un interdite ce
reportage prenant la suite de celui
diffusé en 2019 qui avait chamboulé
notre société à l'époque nous montre à
nouveau le quotidien
inacceptable de certains enfants confiés
à l'aide sociale à l'enfance
nous ne pouvons détourner le regard face
à ces situations d'une extrême gravité
qui ont lieu dans certains départements
la responsabilité de ces situations est
partagée je souhaite tout de même
souligner que la majorité des
professionnels du chant de la protection
de l'enfant font un travail formidable
dans l'accompagnement de ses enfants
vulnérables
par ailleurs je veux également saluer le
travail des associations notamment
d'anciennes enfants placés depuis cinq
ans nous agissons pour que ces
situations deviennent de plus en plus
rares et disparaissent par la loi visant
à protéger les enfants dont j'ai été
rapporteur nous avons voté
l'interdiction du placement en hôtel
bien que son application soit prévue en
2024 pour permettre au département de
s'adapter pour protéger les enfants nous
avons rendu systématique le contrôle des
antécédents judiciaires de tous les
professionnels et bénévoles intervenants
auprès des enfants dans des
établissements pour mine et pas
seulement à l'embauche nous avons
également valorisé les assistants
familiaux par la mise en place d'une
rémunération minimale plus récemment ici
notre présidente a annoncé notre
président de l'Assemblée nationale a
annoncé la création d'une délégation des
droits des enfants demandez de longues
dates je souhaite saluer sa présidence
notre collègue Perrine Goulet qui a
œuvré depuis de longues années pour la
protection de l'enfance et je sais que
nous continuerons à nous investir pour
faire avancer ces problématiques madame
la ministre quelle réponse
supplémentaire le gouvernement peut-il
apporter merci Madame merci beaucoup ma
chère collègues la parole est à Madame
Charlotte cobel secrétaire d'État chargé
de l'enfance
madame la Présidente Mesdames Messieurs
les Députés madame la députée Michel
perron personne je dis bien personne ne
doit détourner le regard face au drame
et aux dysfonctionnements qui ont été à
nouveau relatés dans ce reportage que
vous évoquez madame la députée ces
images sont bien sûr intolérables parce
qu'elles concernent des enfants et des
enfants dont la vie est déjà fracturée
cabossé nous devons donc tous tous
prendre nos responsabilités le président
de la République a pris ses
responsabilités en plaçant l'enfance et
la protection de l'enfance au cœur de ce
quinquennat le gouvernement et la
majorité ont pris leur responsabilité
avec la loi du 7 février 22 qui et vous
en étiez madame la députée il est
maintenant de ma responsabilité de la
mettre concrètement en œuvre j'y
travaille avec détermination avec
l'ensemble membres du gouvernement
concerné notamment pour renforcer les
contrôles des antécédents judiciaires de
tous les professionnels qui entourent
nos enfants notamment par exemple pour
mettre effectivement fin au placement
des enfants dans les hôtels sociaux je
veux m'appuyer sur les comités
départementaux de la protection de
l'enfance prévue par la loi qui
réuniront autour des préfets les
procureurs de la République les recteurs
les directeurs d'Ars et bien sûr les
l'ensemble des acteurs pour répondre au
mieux aux situations de chaque enfant en
danger les présidents des départements
que nous avons vu alors congrès veulent
aussi assurer leur responsabilité y
compris les présidents qui sont
impliqués dans ce reportage mais je le
dis les dates l'État doit faire
davantage encore et c'est pourquoi j'ai
proposé dans le projet de loi de
finances que vous êtes en train
d'examiner le recrutement de plus 50
pour renforcer les contrôles de
l'ensemble des services et des actions
qui sont voilà nous devons agir tous
responsables il en va de nos enfants
protégés et des professionnels
pour le groupe les républicains la
parole est à monsieur Éric Poget
[Applaudissements]
je veux avoir une pensée pour Lola
victime d'un crime abominable en tant
que député je me joins à l'émotion
nationale mais en tant que père je
m'incline devant la douleur d'une
famille brisée et un consolable
l'horreur n'a pas de nom la barbarie n'a
pas d'excuses et si la pudeur aurait dû
m'empêcher de vous poser cette question
la colère n'a pu m'en dissuader
monsieur le ministre elle s'appelait
Lola elle avait 12 ans et elle avait
toute la vie devant elle mais par
faiblesse de la République elle a vécu
la douleur la torture la barbarie en
plein Paris
par le laxisme de votre politique
d'immigration cet enfant a été martyrisé
violet tué par une clandestine qui
faisait pourtant l'objet d'une
obligation de quitter le territoire
français
le défaut d'exécution de ses décisions
de justice
rend votre ministère responsable de ces
drames et je regrette d'avoir à vous
l'imputer mais les chiffres de votre
administration sont implacables
80% des auqtf ne sont toujours pas
exécutés en France et le nombre de
retours forcés vers l'Algérie a chuté de
94% entre 2020 et 2021
lola a perdu la vie parce que vous
n'avez pas procédé à l'expulsion de
cette ressortissante qui n'avait plus
rien à faire ici voilà la lourde
conséquence de votre inaction enfin je
ne sais pas si la justice des hommes
pour être à la hauteur de
l'impardonnable mais je réclame un droit
au procès pour Lola la France ne serait
tolérée ni responsabilité pénale de ces
bourreaux qui n'ont leur place que dans
l'avion ou en prison
oui l'expulsion des délinquants
étrangers doit être une obligation et
automatique car une fois de plus le lien
entre immigration incontrôlée
la parole est à monsieur
Éric Dupond-Moretti garde des sceaux
ministre de la justice
s'il vous plaît
[Musique]
une petite fille de 12 ans
est morte dans des conditions atroces
je pense monsieur le député comme vous à
ses parents
écrasé par le poids de ce chagrin
on essaie de rapatrier le corps de cet
enfant
de là où la famille est originaire
celle qui fait figure de
principal suspecte
à 24 ans elle est inconnue des services
de police
sauf
qu'elle a été victime semble-t-il de
violence et c'est comme ça que les
services de police la connaissent
le 22 août une qtf a été délivrée sans
obligation
de quitter immédiatement le territoire
national il s'agit d'un départ
volontaire pardon il n'y avait il n'y
avait aucune raison qu'il en fut
autrement c'est nos règles et nous ne
savons pas au moment où je vous parle si
un recours n'a pas été intenté par
l'avocat de cette jeune femme pour le
reste je vais vous dire les choses comme
je l'ai ressent faire de la petite
politique de la petite poloche
se servir du cercueil d'une gamine de 12
ans comme on se sert d'un marche-pied
c'est une honte monsieur le député
ne rajoutez pas à l'atrocité la plus
absolue le commerce indigne de la
démagogie et je pense que le meilleur
reste à venir dans quelques instants car
vous êtes toujours au rendez-vous du
malheur dont vous faites depuis des
années votre miel
[Applaudissements]
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
s'il vous plaît
la parole est un s'il vous plaît un peu
de calme la parole est à Madame Sophie
tailler polluant pour le groupe
écologiste
merci madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre mes chers collègues
nous sommes face à une crise sociale
majeure le pays est bloqué
ceci est votre responsabilité car votre
politique se résume à des incantations
face au salaire trop bas
Monsieur le Maire a demandé gentiment
aux entreprises d'augmenter les salaires
en janvier
en mai en juin en juillet
en août et encore il y a cinq jours quel
est le résultat aucun cela ne marche pas
c'est vrai que vous avez peut-être un
petit problème de crédibilité après
avoir augmenté les fonctionnaires de
seulement 3 et demi pour cent quand on
sait que c'est notoirement insuffisant
face à l'inflexion conjuguée au gel des
salaires pendant des années
la perte de pouvoir Macha de pouvoir
d'achat elle est massive pour les
salariés entendez la réalité du pays
à cause de votre inaction et à défaut de
votre soutien les salariés en sont
réduits soit à se taire soit à se mettre
en grève c'est pas facile de faire grève
ça nécessite du courage et des
sacrifices mais pourquoi le font-ils
pour vivre dignement de leur travail si
effectivement comme vous le dites sans
arrêt vous respectez le travail alors
arrêtez de protéger les actionnaires et
les super profits augmenter le SMIC et
le point d'indice correctement
conditionnez les milliards d'euros
d'aide aux entreprises à des politiques
salariales dignes à l'encadrement des
écarts de salaire alors madame la
Première ministre comment comptez-vous
résoudre la crise sociale dont vous êtes
responsable
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Olivier du top ministre du
Travail du plein emploi et de
l'insertion
merci madame la Présidente
de vous retrouver ici j'ai eu l'occasion
de répondre à ces mêmes questions
lorsque vous étiez natrice il est encore
quelques mois mais je vois que vous avez
une forme de Constance mais une
constance à une constance à travers la
réalité une constance à travers la
réalité parce que la réalité dans ce
pays c'est que nous protégeons le
pouvoir d'achat comme personne ne l'a
jamais fait je ne reviens pas sur les
éléments que j'ai évoqué tout à l'heure
mais la loi du mois de juillet a apporté
des éléments supplémentaires tant sur
les questions de tarif en matière
d'énergie que sur les questions de
partage de valeur la valeur vous évoquez
l'augmentation du SMIC il a augmenté de
8% c'est supérieur à l'inflation et
c'est tant mieux cela permet à la fois
de protéger le salaire et le pouvoir
d'achat de ceux qui sont le moins bien
rémunérés mais ça invite aussi ça amène
aussi automatiquement les branches à
revoir les minimas conventionnels à
ouvrir des négociations et depuis le 1er
août ce ne sont pas moins de 60 branches
qui le font c'est automatique parce que
c'est prévu par la loi et d'ailleurs la
loi du mois de juillet grâce à la
majorité a réduit à 45 jours c'était les
maximum pour ouvrir le dialogue de
bronche autour de la négociation des
minimas conventionnels vous nous dites
que nous sommes responsables des
blocages alors que vous même entretenez
des mouvements qui n'ont plus lieu
d'être la réalité madame la députée
c'est que vous vivez dans votre monde
vous pouvez dans votre monde et vous ne
partagez rien des difficultés des
Français et vous ne voyez rien ni des
efforts ni de l'efficacité des résultats
que nous avons
merci Monsieur le Ministre madame
tailler paulian merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Ministre Sénat
vous évitez les attaques personnelles
alors qu'ici évidemment vous le faites
monsieur le monsieur le ministre dans
des deux premiers trimestres les
salaires réels ont chuté de 1,9 et 3% et
le pouvoir d'achat par unité de
consommation 1,8% et 1,2%. la réalité
sociale elle est là elle n'est pas dans
vos éléments de langage qui ne trompent
personne
je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Xavier
Albertini pour le groupe horizon merci
madame la Présidente mes chers collègues
ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'économie des finances et
de la souveraineté industrielle et
numérique j'ai associé ma collègue lise
Magnier monsieur le ministre le 20
septembre dernier à straseneca annoncé
la fermeture en 2024 de son site de
conditionnement et de distribution de
Reims les 120 salariés redoutés depuis
des mois se couperaient l'annonce de
cette fermeture est un paradoxe nous
parlons là d'une multinationale
florissante qui réalise plus de 31 37
milliards d'euros de chiffre d'affaires
pour l'année 2021
l'usine de Reims existe depuis 50 ans et
fait partie du patrimoine industriel de
notre ville cette fermeture annoncée est
donc que tout un symbole c'est la
stratégie d'un géant pharmaceutique qui
après avoir racheté en 2020 ce site va
censé parer à peine 4 ans plus tard
préférant investir dans des destinations
plus exotiques à l'heure du défi de la
souveraineté pharmaceutique mise en
exergue par la crise sanitaire que la
France a connu alors d'une prise de
conscience collective et européenne sur
la nécessaire et industrialisation de
nos territoires cette fermeture d'usine
n'est mise envisageable ni entendable ni
acceptable ce type de situation il en
existe partout en France nous devons
collectivement relever le défi de la
réindustrialisation de notre pays et
plus encore développé nos filières
souveraines l'exemple Rémois se retrouve
dans nombre de circonscriptions les
difficultés sont réelles et concrètes
c'est autant de salariés inquiets pour
leur emploi leur reconversion leur
formation et leur avenir tout simplement
pour autant la partie n'est pas terminée
elle ne fait que commencer à Reims comme
ailleurs en France les accompagne ces
hommes et ces femmes qui se battent pour
conserver leur emploi ces mêmes élus
locaux se battent aussi au quotidien
pour convaincre des groupes d'investir
sur leur territoire parce que nous le
savons l'annonce d'une fermeture est
toujours une fragilisation violente de
toute bassin de vie monsieur le ministre
même si nous vivons dans une économie
mondialisée nos concitoyens eux aspirent
à garder un environnement professionnel
et de vie stable et sereins que
prévoyez-vous pour non seulement
conserver nos emplois industriels mais
surtout sur nos territoires les
développer je vous remercie je vous
remercie la parole est à Monsieur Bruno
Le Maire ministre de l'Économie des
Finances de la souveraineté industrielle
et numérique
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Député Albertini
à se résenneca a effectivement annoncé
son intention de fermer le site de Reims
119 salariés qui sont concernés nous
sommes en discussion avec AstraZeneca
quelque soit la décision finale qui sera
prise les salariés ont droit à un
accompagnement exemplaire pour chaque
salarié et ils ont droit également à une
reprise du site laquelle nous vous
proposons de travailler avec vous
s'agissant du groupe AstraZeneca je
rappelle qu'il a décidé d'investir 450
millions d'euros en France notamment sur
un site je ne pense pas que c'est à lui
qu'on faisait référence parlant de site
exotiques le site de Dunkerque avec tous
les emplois qui vont avec plus
globalement nos stratégies de
réindustrialisation du pays elle donne
des résultats des décisions qui ont été
prises par la première ministre par le
Président de la République depuis
plusieurs années de baisse des impôts de
production de soutien d'un apprentissage
de soutien à l'innovation et à
l'investissement avec et 30 milliards
d'euros de France 2030 par quoi est-ce
que ça se traduit pour la première fois
depuis 20 ans
la France ouvre plus d'usines qu'elle
enferme pour la première fois depuis 20
ans nous recréons des emplois
industriels sur la durée du quinquennat
c'est près de 20 000 emplois nets côté
créés dans l'induscie française donc
notre détermination est totale avec la
première ministre et le président de la
République avec toute cette majorité à
accélérer la réindustrialisation du pays
en investissant dans l'innovation en
baissant les impôts de production en
supprimant les 8 milliards d'euros de
CVAE en rendant nos entreprises plus
compétitives en accélérant la formation
la qualification des salariés la France
a toujours été une grande nation
industrielle elle a connu 30 ans de
délocalisation nous avons inversé le
mouvement et nous allons accélérer
je vous remercie
la parole est à madame la Présidente Le
Pen
merci madame la Présidente
ma question s'adresse à madame la
Première ministre
vendredi le temps s'est arrêté un
instant pour chacun d'entre nous
la France s'est figée de stupeur de
douleur et d'horreur en apprenant le
supplice de la petite Lola cette jeune
collégienne dont la vie a été enlevée en
plein jour et en plein Paris de la pire
des manières qui soient la compassion du
pays à l'égard de sa famille dont chacun
a conscience qu'elle pourrait être la
nôtre est profonde
une fois de plus la suspecte de cet acte
barbare n'aurait pas dû se trouver sur
notre territoire et ce depuis plus de 3
ans
une fois de trop
et vous ne pourrez pas évacuer le sujet
comme vous le faites en toute
circonstance et comme vient de le faire
le ministre de l'injustice en criant à
la récupération et en attaquant par cet
argument éculé ceux qui sont scandalisés
trop de crimes et de délits sont commis
par des immigrés clandestins que l'on
n'a pas voulu ou pas su renvoyer chez
eux le préfet l'allemand l'écrit
lui-même dans son livre un délit sur
deux à Paris dit-il est commis par un
étranger souvent en situation
irrégulière 100 fois madame la Première
ministre nous vous avons interpellé sur
ce laxisme migratoire sur ses
obligations de quitter le territoire
dont 90% ne sont pas exécutés je l'ai
encore fait le 12 juillet dernier sans
réponse
la prise de parole pour le moins tardive
du gouvernement sur cette insoutenable
assassinat prouve que vous n'avez pas
mesuré l'immense la profonde émotion
qu'a suscité ce drame dans le cœur du
peuple français cette dommage vous nous
devez pourtant d'apporter des réponses
et des solutions
urgentes et intransigeantes pour que la
loi soit appliquée et respecté dans
notre pays car aux Français vous devez
la protection de la loi merci madame la
Première ministre
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la
Présidente Le Pen un peu de décence
madame la Présidente
un peu de décence et respecté respecter
la douleur de la famille madame la
Présidente
alors bien sûr il n'y a pas de mots pour
exprimer exprimer la douleur d'une
famille face à la perte d'un enfant le
président de la République a reçu ce
matin les parents de Lola et il a pu
leur exprimer toute l'émotion et toute
la solidarité de la nation et je
souhaite devant vous au nom du
gouvernement et je pense en notre nom à
tous leur m'associer à la peine de cette
famille madame la Présidente
une peine d'autant plus forte compte
tenu des circonstances dramatiques des
circonstances horribles de ce crime en
effet madame la Présidente mais vous
voyez face à un drame d'abord respectons
la douleur de la famille et laissons la
police et la justice faire son travail
et la police fait son travail elle le
fait vite et la justice fait son travail
et elle le fait vite c'est ce qui a
permis d'interpeller d'identifier puis
d'interpeller la prévenu
et de déférer et de déférer cette
prévenue devant la justice et notre
responsabilité à tous et de laisser la
justice punir ce crime à la hauteur de
ce qu'il mérite mais je vous le dis
madame la Présidente dans notre pays il
y a une loi fondamentale qui prévoit la
séparation des pouvoirs respectons la
loi fondamentale respectons la douleur
de la famille respectons la mémoire de
Lola
[Applaudissements]
je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Pascal Lavergne
pour le groupe Renaissance merci madame
la Présidente merci mes chers collègues
ma question s'adresse au mini ministre
de l'Agriculture et de la souveraineté
alimentaire monsieur le ministre comme
un Français sur trois je viens de la
ruralité de là où je viens comme dans
bien d'autres endroits en France dans
ces terres dans berdanos dit qu'elles
sont l'âme de la France la viticulture
est une tradition un savoir-faire et
surtout une fierté en France on fait du
van depuis plus de 2000 ans la
viticulture c'est 45 milliards d'euros
de chiffre d'affaires plus de 15
milliards d'euros d'exportation une
véritable entreprise du CAC 40 elle
représente plus de 650 000 emplois non
délocalisables sur 20 000 communes et 66
départements tout au long de l'histoire
la viticulture a fait vivre le monde
paysan et le monde rural récemment les
crises qui se sont succédées les taxes
Trump la crise covid et la
déconsommation aujourd'hui dans mon
département de la Gironde j'entends les
cris des viticulteurs et l'angoisse face
à l'absence de perspective nombre
d'entreprises alors que les vendanges
sont terminés avec déchets plains sont
au bord du gouffre financier alors
qu'elles ont eu massivement recours au
PGE pendant la crise covid les
viticulteurs ne savent pas comment
rembourser de nombreux défis nous
guettent la reconversion d'une partie du
vignoble et plus généralement les outils
de régulation la transition
agro-environnementale et la protection
contre les aléas climatiques à ce sujet
et plus récemment la crise énergétique
et la hausse du prix des carburants font
gonfler les coûts de production dans la
viticulture mais plus largement dans
toutes les activités agricoles dont on
connaît l'enjeu de souveraineté monsieur
le ministre je viens la tradition
politique où il a qui longtemps a estimé
que faire de la politique s'était
raconté une histoire tracer une ligne
donner un cap quelle perspective pour la
viticulture demain et quand visage le
gouvernement pour répondre au péril des
viticulteurs et aux inquiétudes des
hausses du coup de l'énergie plus
largement en agriculture
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur
Marc phéno ministre de l'Agriculture et
de la souveraineté alimentaire merci
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
la viande vous m'interrogez sur la
situation de la viticulture ayant
particulier dans votre région vous avez
raison de soulever la force la force
économique la force en termes de
commerce extérieur et la part d'identité
que recèle la viticulture comme toute
l'agriculture française mais vous
m'évoquez évidemment un certain nombre
de sujets de difficultés j'aurais évoqué
quatre sujets que vous avez mis sur la
table qui sont des sujets qui relèvent
de domaine structurels ou de domaines
conjoncturels vous m'avez interrogé sur
le PG les difficultés de remboursement
effectivement nous avons bien cela dans
le SCOP qui vous permettez cette
expression et nous travaillons avec les
équipes de Bruno Le Maire pour regarder
ce que nous pouvons faire mais sans
attendre nous avons écrit avec Bruno Le
Maire un courrier au banque pour leur
demander de faire diligence pour
regarder dossier par dossier ainsi que
la même demande a été faite auprès des
préfets pour regarder dossiers pour par
dossier ce que nous pouvons faire dès à
présent vous m'interrogez ensuite sur la
question de la protection contre les
aléas climatiques vous rappelez
simplement que l'État a été au
rendez-vous lors de l'épisode de gel de
2021 plus d'un milliard d'euros les
plans le plan continue à se déployer sur
l'ensemble du territoire national nous
avons été aussi en rendez-vous sur la
grège j'étais d'ailleurs dans votre
département au mois de juin lors de
l'épisode de grêle 40 millions d'euros
qui continuent à être déployés en
fonction des situations locales et puis
évidemment je ne peux pas ne pas évoquer
la situation de l'assurance récolte
c'est une réforme structurelle que nous
avons sur la table que vous avez voté
dans cette assemblée et qui va permettre
aux agriculteurs d'être mieux couvert
sur les questions énergétiques nous
avons les sujets français des sujets
européens le Conseil européen de Prague
permettra sans doute de lever un certain
nombre de contraintes de contraintes de
décoration de prix et de plafonnement
des prix en tout cas nous l'espérons par
ailleurs les dispositifs vont être
ajustés pour faire en sorte que
l'agriculture qui a un cycle de
production particulière plus mieux
bénéficier des dispositifs enfin je
voudrais rappeler ce qui a été fait en
mobilisant les outils de régulation
c'est bien ça qui est le sujet qui est
l'objet de la réunion que nous tiendrons
après ces questions au gouvernement à
votre demande et un certain nombre de
députés pour avoir des outils de
régulation la distillation le stockage
la réserve de tout cela sont des
éléments qui sont sur la table d'autres
éléments sont sur la table nous y
travaillons avec la filière et je compte
que de cette réunion puisse sortir un
certain nombre de propositions que nous
analyserons merci je vous remercie
monsieur le ministre la parole est à
Marie-Noëlle baptistel pour le groupe
socialiste
merci beaucoup madame la présidente
madame la Première ministre EDF est
aujourd'hui contrainte devant à perte
une partie de son électricité d'origine
nucléaire à ses concurrents qui peuvent
la reprendre à un prix fort sur le
marché réalisant ainsi un bénéfice très
important comme certains qui font
l'actualité ce mécanisme pervers que je
dénonce de longues dates et qui a pour
conséquence le saccage financier de EDF
à un an l'arène le seul relèvement de 20
terawatts auquel vous avez procédé a
déjà coûté 8,4 milliards d'euros à EDF
donc à l'étang en 2022 le 21 décembre
2021 la Commission de régulation de
l'énergie publiée la liste des
bénéficiaires de ce mécanisme parmi eux
figure la compagnie gazière
Gazprom c'est le bras armé de la Russie
dont sa guerre du gaz contre l'Europe
madame la Première ministre avons-nous
laissé Gazprom bénéficier en 2022 d'une
électricité subventionnée par EDF et
donc par son actionnaire majoritaire les
Français première victime de l'explosion
des prix de l'énergie si oui sur quel
volume plus largement quel volume
d'électricité ont été délivrés par EDF à
chacun des bénéficiaires c'est une
demande que j'ai évidemment déjà formulé
à la creux à plusieurs reprises sans
réponse il me semble que la
représentation nationale doit en avoir
la communication je vous remercie je
vous remercie la parole est à Madame
Agnès panière une hache et ministre de
la transition énergétique
merci madame la présidente madame
mesdames et messieurs les députés madame
la députée baptistel vous savez comme
moi que le mécanisme de la reine sur
lequel on peut discuter de ses effets à
moyen terme et notamment de son impact
sur
l'objectif qui lui avait été imputé à
savoir développer de nouveaux de
nouvelles capacités de production
électrique c'est une très bonne
discussion mais je vais revenir sur le
propos que vous avez formulé aujourd'hui
la reine bénéficie au consommateurs
d'électricité il bénéficie au ménage qui
n'avait pas accès aux tarif régulé il
bénéficie aux entreprises qui n'ont pas
accès au tarif régulé il bénéficie aux
collectivités locales qui ne bénéficient
pas de l'accès aux tarif régulés vous le
savez on l'a dit plusieurs fois sur ces
bancs c'est ça qui a permis cette année
de préserver 45 000 emplois industriels
dans 150 entreprises dont certaines que
vous avez suivi très près je pense à
faire open vous le savez aussi que c'est
ça qui a permis de faire un
tampon sur l'augmentation des prix de
l'électricité puisque pour les
collectivités locales c'est plus 20% au
lieu de plus 40 % pour les électro
intensifs les entreprises qui consomme
beaucoup d'électricité c'est un prix de
plus 40 ou 60% auxquels elles auraient
dû faire face alors s'il vous plaît
madame baptistel ne confondons pas les
sujets la reine qui est un mécanisme qui
a bénéficié au consommateurs et les
sujets des producteurs d'électricité ou
des distributeurs sur lequel nous avons
avec la creux mis des contrôles et dont
nous allons renforcer les pouvoirs de
sanctions de la creux pour qu'elles
n'utilise pas des mécanismes de manière
indue je vous remercie je vous remercie
madame batistel
oui madame la ministre je note que vous
ne m'avez pas répondu sur la question
très précise de Gazprom parce que je
pense que les consommateurs n'en sont
pas bénéficiaires comme vous le dites et
du coup dans la même logique
prévoyez-vous toujours de laisser
rosatum la compagnie des tarus prendre
20% des parts dans le cadre du rachat de
Général Electric des turbines arabels
qui est aussi le fleuron de notre
industrie nucléaire c'est un peu le même
sujet moi je souhaite que vraiment la
Creuse nous donne à la fois la liste des
bénéficiaires de la reine et les volumes
qui lui sont attribués je pense que
c'est quelque chose qui doit être
hublique aujourd'hui nous n'avons que la
liste de 2021 sur laquelle figure
Gazprom est la liste de 2021 nous ne
l'avons pas je vous remercie la parole
est à Monsieur Manuel Bompard pour le
groupe la France insoumise merci madame
la présidente madame la Première
ministre aujourd'hui a lieu une journée
de grève nationale pour l'augmentation
des salaires elle fait suite aux
formidable succès de la marche contre la
vie chère organisée dimanche dernier ce
mouvement à notre soutien total les
salariés ont raison d'exiger des
salaires plus hauts pour faire face à la
hausse des prix alors que l'inflation
atteint 6% le salaire moyen dans le
privé n'a augmenté que de 3,1%. quand au
point d'indice des fonctionnaires il n'a
progressé en juillet que de 3,5%. très
concrètement les salariés du public
comme du privé perdent donc du pouvoir
d'achat alors que dans le même temps les
plus riches se gavent la France a
atteint cette année un record de
dividendes en hausse de 33%. votre
responsabilité est totale dans cette
situation depuis des mois nous vous
proposons d'augmenter le SMIC pour
mettre fin à cette injustice mais vous
l'avez refusé main dans la main avec le
rassemblement national depuis des mois
nous vous proposons de taxer les supers
profits de rétablir l'impôt de
solidarité sur la fortune mais vous
l'avez refusé main dans la main avec le
rassemblement national
à la place vous demandez timidement aux
entreprises de faire des gestes pour
seule réponse le patron total s'est
augmenté de 52%, tout en refusant de
négocier avec les salariés avant que
ceux-ci se mettent en grève face à ces
blocages les salariés en raison de se
mobiliser après une journée de grève les
chauffeurs routiers de Laval ont obtenu
une augmentation de 6,9%. la grève peut
parfois remplir le frigo n'en déplaises
à Monsieur Attal madame la Première
ministre vous êtes minoritaire dans la
société comme dans cette assemblée 79%
des Français sont pour le rétablissement
de l'ISF 67% pour la hausse du SMIC 80%
pour la taxation des super profits alors
ma question est simple allez-vous madame
la Première ministre continue à bloquer
le pays où aller voir enfin porter le
SMIC à 1600 euros net et convoquait une
conférence sociale pour l'augmentation
des salaires
je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Olivier Duchamp
ministre du Travail du plein emploi et
de l'insertion merci Monsieur le prix
madame la Présidente pardonnez-moi
monsieur le député Bombard
je ne sais pas si je dois sourire ou pas
parce que la question est sérieuse elle
pense sur le pouvoir d'achat ce qui est
sûr c'est que ce n'est pas à moi de
commenter le succès ou les chats d'une
manifestation 29000 personnes ce n'est
pas si mal c'est loin de l'estimation
qui est la vôtre
c'est loin de votre estimation mais j'ai
parfois le sentiment que vous avez la
même capacité à estimer les participants
et les manifestation qui a estimé la
réalité de la politique du gouvernement
et de ses résultats sur le pouvoir
d'achat nous avons fait le choix je le
répète de protéger le pouvoir d'achat et
d'engager des boucliers et des mesures
que aucun autre pays en Europe n'a
engagé nous avons fait le choix de
dynamiser la négociation dans les
branches collectives en nous appuyant
sur l'augmentation automatique du SMIC à
8%. puis la grande différence monsieur
le député entre vous et nous c'est que
nous faisons confiance au dialogue
social confiance au dialogue social pour
que dans les branches les solutions
soient trouvées dans le respect de
chacune des parties confiance dans le
dialogue social pour sortir des conflits
et nous faisons confiance aussi au
dialogue social quand il aboutit à des
accords qui sont les accords
majoritaires ce qui nous incite aussi à
encourager à la reprise du travail
monsieur le député vous avez une espèce
de mantra qui s'inscrit dans le village
Potemkine de votre réalité sociale nous
agissons nous agissons pour protéger le
pouvoir d'achat vous vous contentez
d'arranguer les foules vous c'est le
blocage du pays nous souhaitons la
réussite de notre pays vous souhaitez
finalement que la misère prospère parce
que la misère c'est votre fond de
commerce
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
la parole est à Monsieur Antoine vers
Morel Marc pour le groupe les
républicains
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à Madame la première minute
madame la Première ministre après le
confinement sanitaire est venu le temps
du confinement énergétique l'électricité
plus 10%. le gaz + 34%, le fuel + 70 %
pire encore des millions de Français ne
trouvent même plus de carburant pour
circuler après le temps de la vie chère
est venu le temps de la France en
carence carence de carburant et carence
de gouvernement car les Français sont
fatigués d'entendre que tout va bien
alors qu'ils attendent des heures pour
faire le plein les Français sont
fatigués de voir leur gouvernement
réagir trop peu ou trop tard l'effort
les Français sont fatigués de chercher
des produits qui disparaissent des
rayons les Français sont fatigués de
voir leur pays s'enfoncer chaque jour
davantage car derrière l'arbre des
carburants se cache la forêt des
pénuries cela avait commencé il y a
quelques mois avec la moutarde et
l'huile de tournesol aujourd'hui la
France n'a même plus de quoi circuler et
demain elle ne pourrait même plus avoir
de quoi se chauffer après les
raffineries ce sont nos centrales
nucléaires qui se mettent en grève
allez-vous là aussi attendre des jours
pour réagir aux grèves préventives nous
demandons des actions préventives
qu'attendez-vous pour acquisitionner
toutes les raffineries qu'attendez-vous
madame la Première ministre pour dire
comme votre Ministre de l'économie que
ce mouvement des raffineries est
illégitimes et inacceptable
qu'attendez-vous pour joindre la parole
aux actes et permettre aux Français de
se déplacer et vivre librement
je vous remercie la parole
Etam Madame Agnès renacher ministre de
la transition énergétique
des entreprises et des accords
majoritaires conclus car nous avons
ramenés et total et Esso à la table de
négociation et nous avons aujourd'hui
des accords majoritaires qu'est-ce
qu'aurait dit sur ces bancs de
l'Assemblée nos députés si nous avions
réquisitionné tout et n'importe quoi
sans respecter le dialogue social sans
respecter la démocratie sociale
qu'est-ce que vous auriez dit vous si
nous n'avions pas agi en réquisitionnant
à juste de la juste manière pour pouvoir
approvisionner les Français alors nous
agissons de manière équilibrée de
manière respectueuse de la démocratie
mais au service des Français et nous
allons continuer à le faire
je vous remercie allez-y mon cher
collègue est parfaite pouvez-vous
expliquer aux habitants de ma
circonscription pourquoi ce matin encore
il ne pouvait pas trouver de carburant
et pourquoi dans votre réponse vous êtes
incapable de nous donner une date où
toutes les stations d'essence pourront
retrouver de carburant en France
je vous remercie
la parole est à monsieur Guillaume
vuittet pour le groupe Renaissance merci
de la présidence de mes châtelègue ma
question s'adresse c'est monsieur le
garde des sceaux deux villes de lieu le
lieu où Samuel Paty a vécu celui ou
Sabine Patty a transmis et rémy-sur-oise
et Conflans-Sainte-Honorine de ville où
il fait bon vivre et qui sont
aujourd'hui marqués sont par son martyr
deux villes où nombre de nos concitoyens
ressenti le besoin de se retrouver ce
dimanche 16 octobre deux ans après le
drame dans des cérémonies un peu
différentes mais dans le sens était le
même la République n'oubliera pas la
République ne cédera pas dans ces deux
endroits le même voile de tristesse les
mêmes accolades pour partager un peu de
chaleur et le même silence deux
cérémonies dignes ou les mêmes mots
raisonnés le respect absolu pour Samuel
Paty la même dénonciation de l'Alliance
abject entre la bêtise et la haine la
même force dans la lutte contre le
terrorisme islamiste il fallait aussi
rappeler ce qu'était la mission de
Samuel Paty ce à quoi il a consacré sa
vie l'apprentissage aux adolescents des
valeurs qui nous font vivre ensemble et
de notre histoire dont ces valeurs sont
le produit leur apprendre combien la
République était non-spatrice combien
elle garantit le respect de leur
conviction de l'évolution de celle-ci de
partager les doutes et des contreverses
il était indispensable de rappeler aussi
la laïcité n'est que mais c'est
fondamental la liberté de conscience et
la neutralité de l'autorité publique
ceux qui ont manipulé le terrorisme
n'ont pas choisi leur cible par hasard
ce sont celles et ceux qui apportent
savoir qui ont été atteints ce sont ceux
qui apportent cette lumière à nos
enfants les adolescents étaient là
dimanche aussi marqués digne recueillis
et je vais aussi parler de ses proches
au regard dévasté de ce tout jeune
garçon à qui nous devons dire que nous
serons toujours là
à la fin de chacun de ces moments il m'a
été posé la même question toute simple
qu'est-ce qui a changé depuis ce jour
terrible alors j'ai parlé de la loi
séparatisme de l'action du gouvernement
sur la haine en ligne de la lutte contre
le radicalité j'ai décris tout cela mais
je crois que nous concitoyens ont besoin
d'entendre la voix du gouvernement alors
je vais simplement vous transmettre
cette question monsieur le garde des
sceaux qu'est-ce qui a changé depuis ce
terrible 16 octobre 2020
je vous remercie
la parole est à Éric Dupont-Moretti
garde des sceaux ministre de la justice
monsieur le député Guillaume Vittel
ce qui a changé c'est
d'abord le choc considérable
et le retentissement considérable de
l'assassinat de Samuel Paty
on assassinant cet homme on a voulu tuer
la République
l'État de droit liberté d'expression
d'abord nous avons tous compris qu'il
n'y avait pas de place pour les
inverseurs de culpabilité selon la
formule de la sœur de Samuel Paty
Michael Patty je le dire très clairement
nous ne laisserons pas les activistes
islamistes remettre en cause la loi de
2004 sur le port de signe religieux dans
les établissements scolaires et je le
dis sur le contrôle du ministre de
l'éducation nationale et de madame la
Première ministre ensuite il y a ceux
qui hurlent il y a ceux qui vont s'y
faire il y a les Yaka faucon et puis il
y a ceux qui travaillent et ceux qui
font et au rang de ce que nous avons
fait deux textes législatifs en 2021 de
loi que certains d'ailleurs n'ont pas
voté deux lois successives pour
conforter l'arsenal mise à disposition
des services pour lutter contre les
phénomènes terroristes puis la loi du 30
juillet 21 qui pérennise les
dispositions de la loi silt plus puis la
loi confortant les principes de la
République promulguer le 24 août 2021
que vous n'avez pas voté entre
parenthèses puis davantage de moyens
budgétaires et humains pour la police
les renseignements la justice puis un
suivi psychiatrique sur ce point de
grandes avancées ont été réalisées la
DGSI et les préfets se sont notamment
dotés d'une capacité d'analyse dédiée
puis l'éloignement des ESI inscrits au
FS
prt puis la chute la judiciarisation
prévue bien plus rapidement et notamment
pour les faits d'apologie du terrorisme
puis le renforcement de la plateforme et
la création du Pôle Emploi
merci monsieur le ministre
la parole est à Monsieur Jean-Philippe
Tanguy pour le groupe rassemblement
national
[Applaudissements]
merci à la présidente ma question
s'adresse à Elisabeth borne première
ministre madame la Première ministre le
diesel a 1 euro 50 voici votre promesse
de l'été pour faire passer votre budget
avec les républicains qui décidément ont
la mémoire courte pas nous un seul
groupe un seul groupe a eu le courage de
dire que vous menti aux Français le
rassemblement national et Marine Le Pen
vous mentiez au Leclerc de Montdidier
comme partout dans la Somme comme
partout en France le gazole est à 2
euros parfois 2 euros 40 à la station
Total de Montdidier il n'y a plus rien
car oui votre incompétence ne s'arrête
pas à l'explosion des prix mais le
carburant est introuvable dans plus d'un
tiers des services de francs des
stations services de France vous avez
réussi à placer la cinquième puissance
du monde dans un état de pénurie
permanente vous qui
occupez le siècle de Messmer et Pompidou
vous en êtes réduite à faire la promo
des doudounes à la pénurie de gaz de
bois de produits alimentaires vous
ajoutez la pénurie de carburant bientôt
la pénurie organisée d'électricité vous
étiez ministre de la fermeture de
Fessenheim vous êtes première ministre
des grèves dans nos centrales nucléaires
comme réponse à la crise Emmanuel Macron
promet le tout électrique d'ici 2035
belle promesse qui sacrifie ce qui
marche la filière automobile française
alors que vous n'êtes même pas capable
d'assurer la production électrique pour
les prochains hivers combien de temps
les Français devront payer pour des
erreurs sur TF1 vous avez étalé votre
irresponsable impuissance spectatrice
prisonnière des cabinets de com des
technocats qui contrôlent vos mots vos
actions et peut-être même votre esprit
vous commencez l'écrire vous commentez
les crises car vous les subissez vous
les subissez car vous les incarnez et
vous les incarnez donc vous ne pouvez
les anticiper la macronie et
l'incarnation même du système
mondialiste qui méprisent le travail des
Français vous avez tenté d'étouffer la
dignité des Français avec des chèques
sans provision des coups de matraque
sans humanité maintenant la question est
simple quand allez-vous permettre de
laisser vivre les Français dignement
librement notre travail
merci mon la parole est à Madame Agnès
panière ministre de la transition
énergétique
mais madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Tanguy j'avoue que j'ai attendu la fin
de la question pour savoir exactement
sur quoi elle portait tant le propos
était à la fois éparpillé et peu
conclusif qu'est-ce que nous faisons
monsieur le député Tanguy monsieur le
bébé peut être Tanguy nous agissons nous
agissons au service des Français nous
agissons pour leur donner une vie
meilleure de s'agissons pour bâtir une
souveraineté nous agissons pour les
protéger tels sont les faits où
étiez-vous lorsque nous avons
réindustrialisé réindustrialiser la
France où étiez-vous lorsque nous avons
protégé le pouvoir d'achat avec la
mesure carburant avec les boucliers où
étiez-vous lorsque nous avons voté des
crédits y compris pour renforcer la
sécurité de notre pays avec des
policiers de proximité ou étiez-vous
où étiez-vous lorsqu'il faut voter des
lois importantes et que vous n'êtes pas
dans l'hémicycle où sommes où êtes-vous
alors Monsieur le Député Tanguy revenons
au fait aujourd'hui notre pays et celui
qui a le taux d'inflation le plus faible
d'Europe plus faible également que les
États-Unis plus faibles également que le
Royaume-Uni notre pays et celui qui a le
mieux protégé le pouvoir d'achat des
ménages et des Français et c'est notre
fierté notre pays continue à se battre
pour sa souveraineté énergétique
industrielle et je ne vais pas rappeler
les propos qui ont été formulés par
Monsieur le Ministre de l'économie tout
à l'heure notre pays agit au quotidien
pour faire en sorte de débloquer la
situation et nous ne sommes pas dans la
parole et l'invective nous sommes dans
l'action
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Bruno fucks pour le groupe
démocrate voilà merci beaucoup madame la
Présidente ma question s'adresse à
Monsieur Bruno Le Maire ministre de
l'Économie monsieur le ministre faire de
la France le leader mondial de la
voiture propre et durable voici un
objectif à la mesure de notre ambition
industrielle retrouvée hier par la voie
son directeur général le groupe
stelantis a annoncé que six nouveaux
modèles électriques seront bientôt
produits en France 3 le seront à
Mulhouse dans ma circonscription et
c'est donc en exprimant une grande
fierté et celle de l'ensemble de
l'Alsace que je m'adresse à vous et
pourtant ces modèles avaient toutes les
chances d'être produit à l'étranger je
voudrais remercier le président de la
République et vous même monsieur le
ministre lorsque je vous ai saisi en
mars 2021 de ce risque vous avez su
prendre le temps et convaincre Carlos
Tavares de renoncer à son projet de
délocalisation et de produire en France
alors de la fertile locale c'est une
très grande nouvelle pour la France être
à la hauteur du défi climatique et être
au coeur des mutations de l'automobile
l'objectif du gouvernement est clair une
filière électrique 100% française 8
milliards d'euros d'investissement et de
près publique 2 millions de voitures
produites en 2030 mais pour y arriver il
nous faudra relever un très grand nombre
de défis d'abord un défi
d'infrastructures avec le déploiement
massif de bornes de recharge il nous
faudra aussi être capable de construire
en France des batteries les batteries
c'est 40% de la valeur d'un véhicule il
nous faudra aussi les recycler il faudra
résoudre la question du prix des
véhicules pour qu'ils soient accessible
à tous les ménages il nous faudra
dominer la concurrence internationale
face au constructeurs chinois et
américains et pour cela la réponse est
une amenant européenne nous ne pouvons
rester les bras croisés lorsqu’en
constructeur chinois est soumis à 10% de
droits de douane en Europe alors que en
européen doit 25% lorsqu'il exporte une
voiture en Chine monsieur ministre
pouvez-vous nous dire quelles sont les
politiques publiques qui sont revenus
pour faire de la France un leader
mondial de la voiture propre et durable
et dites nous aussi vos intentions pour
donner un portage européen à cette
politique de reconquête industrielle je
vous remercie la parole est à Monsieur
Bruno Le Maire ministre de l'économie
des finances et de la souveraineté
industrielle et numérique merci madame
la Présidente sur le député Bruno Fuchs
toutes ces annonces de relocalisation
industrielle sont une vraie victoire
industrielle pour la France vous l'avez
cité on peut comprendre le site du
Mulhouse 5000 en points industriels
préservés vous l'avez cité la
relocalisation de la 308 électrique de
la 308 break électrique de la 408 break
électrique à Mulhouse vouillez aussi
citer à 5008 la 5008 break à Sochaux
vous auriez pu citer le trafic à
Sandouville vous auriez pu citer la R4
et la R5 vous auriez pu citer les
projets d'investissement de Renault à
Cléon vous auriez pu citer la création
de la première
usine de batterie électrique totalement
indépendante totalement souveraine à
Douvrin dans le Nord tout cela ce sont
des succès industriels pour la majorité
et pour l'industrie automobile française
nous allons poursuivre dans cette
direction de façon à accélérer le
mouvement de relocalisation industrielle
et être leader sur le domaine de la
voiture électrique
l'étape prendra toute sa responsabilité
vous connaissez notre politique
industrielle formation qualification
baisse des impôts de production soutien
d'investissement soutient l'innovation
cette politique là pour la première fois
a permis d'inverser la tendance de la
délocalisation elle donne des résultats
elle est efficace nous la poursuivons
nous voulons que les constructeurs
jouent le jeu aussi et qu'il relocalise
encore davantage les chiffres que j'ai
donné sont nos premiers chiffres moi ce
que je souhaite c'est que des véhicules
de segments B comme la 208 électrique
c'est-à-dire des petits modèles pour la
première fois depuis des décennies
reviennent de l'étranger en France pour
qu'il se soit des productions nationales
il n'y a aucune raison que les petits
modèles ne soient pas produits sont trop
territoires et j'attends de la part des
constructeurs de la solidarité enfin
dernier acteur l'Union européenne face
aux décisions de la Chine de et des
États-Unis le monsieur Biden nous
souhaitons que l'Union européenne soit
beaucoup plus offensive dans la défense
des intérêts économiques industriels
européens en particulier de l'industrie
automobile merci beaucoup
la parole est à Monsieur Jean-Louis
Bricout pour le groupe liberté
indépendant outre-mer et territoire
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à Monsieur le Ministre de la
Santé et concerne la présence médicale
sur les territoires
certainement par un manque
d'anticipation bon nombre de nos
concitoyens se retrouvent aujourd'hui en
grande détresse faute de médecins
traitant parce qu'il s'agit d'une
urgence sanitaire chacun s'emploie
proposait des solutions à très court
terme et il le faut mais est-ce
suffisant je ne pense pas il faut aussi
agir vite et pour longtemps ne
retomberons pas dans un manque
d'anticipation il faut donc agir
durablement agir durablement pour la
formation des professionnels de santé
pour donner toutes les chances à notre
jeunesse lui fournir une meilleure
condition pour lui donner l'envie de
s'occuper et de soigner l'autre dans ce
cadre et sensible aux initiatives
locales je vous propose avec le groupe
Liot de nous aider à déployer ce que
j'ai appelé les écoles normales de la
santé je vous propose d'intégrer nos
jeunes de la seconde dans des lycées
spécialisés pour la santé des lycées qui
feraient référence sur nos territoires
avec une formation qui épouse deux
modèles celui des formations par filière
c'est le modèle des lycées agricoles
celui des écoles normales de l'éducation
nationale qui ont formé avec succès
plusieurs générations d'enseignants
cette école normale de la santé c'est un
ascenseur social c'est l'agrégation
l'intégration très tôt dans la
communauté de santé et la création d'un
réseau avec les établissements de
proximité des études gratuites la
proposition d'une bourse de vie et en
contrepartie l'engagement de s'installer
sur le territoire de formation de quoi
désamorcer en quelque sorte et en amont
la liberté d'installation si cher à
médecin monsieur le ministre avec les
élus locaux êtes-vous prêt à soutenir ce
type de projet êtes-vous prêt à
l'intégrer à notre projet territoire le
pacte sandre avenois tirage monsieur le
ministre donné cette possibilité
d'expérimenter d'innouver essentiel et
si cher notre groupe je vous remercie je
vous remercie mon cher collègue la
parole est à Madame Agnès Firmin le Bodo
ministre délégué de l'organisation
territoriale et des professions de santé
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le
députés Bricout la lutte contre les
désert médicaux et une des priorités de
ce gouvernement et ce déjà depuis la
dernière mandature d'ailleurs c'est ce
gouvernement qui a supprimé le numerus
clausus et transformé en numéro sapertus
pour anticiper justement à la
problématique qui est la nôtre vous
souhaitez m'interroger sur les enjeux de
formation des professionnels de santé à
ce sujet vous savez nous partageons
votre philosophie il nous faut continuer
de revoir l'ensemble du système depuis
la détection des potentiels leur
accompagnement en par la formation
initiale et continue la
professionnalisation les carrières et
les diversités d'exercices notre
ambition est bien de transformer les
métiers et de construire de nouveaux
cadres d'exercices nous devons augmenter
rapidement les ressources humaines
disponibles et poursuivre nous avancées
pour renforcer leur compétences nous
avons déjà de nombreux outils qu'il nous
faut collectivement mobiliser sur les
territoires sur le plan quantitatif nous
nous assurons bien sûr que les 13500
places créées dans les instituts de
formation se déploient conformément au
calendrier convenu vous parlez
d'anticipation nous rouvrirons donc la
discussion en particulier avec les
régions sur la nouvelle cible qu'il
conviendrait d'atteindre pour répondre
aux besoins de demain et puisqu'il faut
anticiper c'est bien un chantier que
nous avons aussi ouvert avec mon
collègue François Braun sur
l'anticipation à 5 10 15 et 20 ans de
toutes les professions de santé sur le
pont qualitatif il y a aussi un enjeu
fort à mettre en place les conditions
pour éviter l'arrêt des études notamment
sur le métier et les formations
d'infirmières puisque 40% d'étudiants
infirmiers arrêtent la première première
année et accompagner les jeunes sur le
plan social au terme de logements de
transport et de qualité de vie étudiante
nous devons nous donner aussi les moyens
de développer en masse les formations
par l'apprentissage nous souhaitons
aussi développer les contrats
d'engagement de service public qui
permet de rémunérer les étudiants
pendant leurs études en échange d’années
passées ensuite à l'hôpital travailler
pour plus de diversité des profils
inclus dans des formations de santé vous
le voyez monsieur le député tous les
champs sont ouverts la formation est un
de nos enjeux prioritaires pour
permettre le développement des
professions médicales merci beaucoup
madame la ministre la parole est à
Madame Hélène Laporte pour le groupe
rassemblement national merci
madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à Monsieur François Braun
ministre de la Santé monsieur le
ministre le besoin d'un niveau de
qualification intermédiaire entre les
diplômes paramédicaux et le doctorat en
médecine a conduit le législateur à
créer en 2016 l'exercice en pratique
avancée entrée en vigueur en 2018 cette
réforme est située un nouveau diplôme de
niveau Master permettant à des
auxiliaires médicaux d'accomplir
certains actes jusqu'ici réservés aux
seuls médecins y compris certaines
prescriptions dans un contexte de
pénurie gravissime de médecins on
pourrait s'attendre à voir votre
ministère capitalisé sur ce nouvel outil
et encourager au minimum les infirmiers
qu'ils soient jeunes diplômés ou déjà
expérimenté à se tourner vers ce diplôme
pourtant ce n'est pas l'empressement qui
a caractérisé la conduite de vos
prédécesseurs madame Buzin et Monsieur
Veyran ainsi que la vôtre en la matière
vous conservez une grille indiciaire peu
valorisante pour ses professionnels il a
fallu que l'Union nationale des
infirmiers en pratique avancée s'alarent
pour que son enfant institué une prime
dédiée à partir d'avril 2022
déprime de 180 euros soit un peu plus de
deux plaintes gasoil mensuel voilà ce
que vaut pour le ministère de la Santé
le choix courageux pour de jeunes
infirmiers de continuer leurs études
deux ans de plus conséquence directe le
nombre d'infirmiers étudiants en master
de pratiques avancées entre 2021 et 2022
c'est toute jeune discipline est déjà
sur le déclin en 2020 votre ministère
prévoyait 3000 pas pour 2022 et 5000
pour 2024 mais en mars 2022 on ne compte
que 935 diplômés et 1425 infirmiers
étudiants
osons le dire c'est un échec monsieur le
ministre il n'y a pas que Paris la
désertification médicale de nos
territoires ruraux s'aggravent année
après année dans mon département du
Lot-et-Garonne on en arrive dans
certains cantons sinistrés à un tour
d'un médecin pour 3000 habitants la
situation ne nous permet aucune
tergiversation allez-vous enfin créer
les conditions nécessaires pour que les
IPA puisse jouer le rôle qui leur
reviennent dans la lutte contre ce fléau
je vous remercie
je vous remercie la parole est à Madame
Agnès ferme le Bodo ministre délégué
chargé de l'organisation territoriale et
des professions de santé madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés madame la député la porte vous
l'avez dit la France est un désert
médical puisque 87 % de notre territoire
est considéré en zone soudance c'est
bien pour ça que avec le ministre
François braune nous avons faisant suite
aux mesures décider lors de la dernière
législature ouvert tous les champs lors
de la dernière signature le numerus
clausus comme j'ai eu l'occasion de le
dire lors de la question précédente a
été supprimée pour créer le numéro
sapertus nous avons créé les assistants
médicaux qui sont en train d'être
déployés permettant de dégager 15% de
temps médical et nous avons aussi permis
de le développement des IPA nous nous
avons nous le savons tous le sujet des
IPA se situe à deux niveaux tout d'abord
leur place à l'hôpital qui marche plutôt
bien mais la problématique de
l'articulation avec les médecins
généralistes leur place n'a pas encore
été trouvée c'est sur ce sujet sur
lequel nous travaillons collectivement
puisque soutien à le dire ici la semaine
dernière tous les ordres
de profession médicale ont signé ont
signé un pacte un contrat pour nous
permettre de dégager du temps médical
les IPA trouveront leur place au côté
des autres professionnels de santé des
médecins des pharmaciens des kinés des
sages-femmes bien sûr des pédicures
podologues et des chirurgiens autistes
pour nous permettre de dégager du temps
médical nous avons au sujet des IPA un
enjeu un enjeu de formation un enjeu
d'accompagnement des infirmières dans la
formation des IPA et sur le sujet du
conventionnement un accord a été trouvé
lors de du mois cet été j'ai reçu les
IPA il y a pas plus tard que 5 jours et
nous sommes prévus de nous rencontrer
pour de nouveaux améliorer l'enjeu et
l'accès à la formation et peut-être
développer aussi les champs des
compétences dans lequel elle pourrait
être intervenir notamment dans le dans
le champ de la petite enfance où il y a
un vrai enjeu d'accompagnement
je vous remercie madame la ministre la
parole est à Madame merciia soudais pour
le groupe la France insoumise
chers collègues dès 2017 les ordonnances
Macron avait fortement réduit la
capacité d'action des syndicats et les
droits des salariés destruction des
CHSCT recul du paritarisme barème
prud'homo etc 5 ans après le ton n'a pas
changé et malheur à qui ose résister en
faisant grève c'est ce qui lustre le
traitement honteux réservé à kyleterada
professeur de mathématiques à
Joliot-Curie de Nanterre et
syndicalistes chez Sud qui a été
suspendu à la rentrée puis muté d'office
à une heure de trajet de son
établissement d'origine dans un
communiqué du 24 septembre la rectrice
proche d'Emmanuel Macron a présenté
cette mutation comme visant à je cite
reconstruire un climat apaisé résultat
des échauffes fourrés devant le lycée
toute la semaine 14 lycéens en garde à
vue et des tirs de mortiers encore hier
matin wow quel succès comment ne pas
être révolté également par la situation
d'agence CGT de RTE qui pourrait avoir
fait grève ont été mis à pied et puis
arrêtez par la DGSI à leur domicile
menotté et qualifié devant leur famille
de je cite cybercriminel en bande
organisée de subir une garde à vue de 96
heures quand on ne traite pas les
grévistes comme des terroristes on les
réquisitionne comme en ce moment dans
les raffineries pour madame la Première
ministre c'est réquisitions vont
permettre à la situation actuelle de
s'améliorer elle a également demandé aux
salariés grévistes de je cite respecter
les accords majoritaires et de ne pas
bloquer le pays alors que rien
n'obligeant syndicat même minoritaire à
saigner sur ceux qui accompagnent la
politique du gouvernement ou du patronat
ce n'est pas au gouvernement de juger de
la pertinence d'une grève c'est coup de
force sont autant d’âme de faiblesse
d'un gouvernement qui se scène
minoritaire dans le pays et à
l'Assemblée un communiqué de la CGT
indique que je cite le gouvernement a
fait le choix de la violence on écoute
la colère s'il vous plaît la c'est le
dernier refuge de l'incompétence disait
Isaac Asimov jusqu'à quand comptez-vous
piétiner le dialogue social et l'état de
droit
je vous remercie
la parole
est un monsieur Olivier dupe ministre du
Travail du plein emploi et de
l'insertion
monsieur le ministre s'il vous plaît
monsieur le ministre vous avez la parole
merci madame la présidente
madame
la députée vous avez évoqué le droit
syndical et je pense que votre question
appelle une réponse dans le plus grand
calme vous avez évoqué notamment la
question des réquisitions il se trouve
que nous sommes face à un conflit social
un mouvement de protestation dans les
raffineries qui entraîne des
perturbations une atteinte à l'ordre
public et qui pose aussi une question en
matière d'urgence toutes les
réquisitions qui ont été demandées par
le gouvernement et en l'occurrence par
madame la Première ministre dès la
semaine dernière dans les Normandie ou
dans les hauts de France l'ont été faits
en réponse à un impératif d'urgence sont
des réquisitions qui sont proportionnées
et qui garantissent l'exercice du droit
syndical c'est réquisitions ont fait
l'objet de contestation le tribunal
administratif de Lille a apporté une
réponse et plus récemment encore le
tribunal administratif de Rouen du 13
octobre à préciser et a dit que les
réquisitions ne portent pas une atteinte
manifestement disproportionnée à la
liberté fondamentale que constit le
droit de manifester le droit de grève ce
que nous faisons là c'est appliquer la
loi dans le respect du droit syndical et
j'ajoute une phrase j'ajoute une phrase
pour dire que dans un conflit social il
y a un accord majoritaire signé par les
représentants majoritairement du des
salariés la règle de la démocratisation
sociale c'est de respecter cet accord
je vous remercie Monsieur Le Mesnil la
parole est à Madame Nadia est pour le
groupe Renaissance
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre de l'Éducation nationale il y a
deux ans la ville de
Conflans-Sainte-Honorine a vécu un drame
qui a résonné par delà ses écoles ces
rues ses habitants un drame qui a marqué
la France entière dans sa chair et dans
son esprit Samuel Patier dans toutes nos
mémoires la commémoration de sa
disparition chers collègues par-delà nos
oppositions politiques nous obligent
cela nous oblige à ne jamais oublier
nous lui avons rendu hommage dimanche
dernier ensemble unis solidaire et le
plus bel hommage que nous pouvons rendre
à Samuel Paty c'est de poursuivre son
heure et son oeuvre et de neutraliser
ceux qui ont conduit à sa mort
faisons-le dans l'unité nationale pour
nos enfants pour notre jeunesse pour
notre pays
Samuel Paty a rejoint le panthéon de
ceux qui ont porté l'étendard de la
liberté d'expression par le merveilleux
métier d'enseignant qui était le sien
monsieur le ministre dès votre
nomination vous avez choisi de vous
rendre au collège du bois d'aulne pour
lui rendre hommage et pour exprimer
votre émotion votre soutien à ses
collègues à votre famille éducative
notre devoir et devrait à la formation
des citoyens éclairés dans un monde
meurtri par toutes les formes
d'extrémisme et d'obscurantisme et c'est
pourquoi nous avons commencé à mettre en
place des ateliers à Visé philosophiques
expérimentés à Trappes puis mis en place
au niveau national dans nos quartiers
populaires afin de développer dès le
plus jeune âge l'esprit critique le
raisonnement par soi-même l'imprégnation
des principes fondamentaux du dialogue
de l'écoute de la tolérance de
l'altérité en somme tout ce qui fait
République tout ce qui fait notre vivre
ensemble alors Monsieur le Ministre quel
autre mesure phare comptez-vous
développer pour que la France reste pour
toujours le pays des Lumières contre
toutes les formes d'obscurantisme et
d'extrémisme je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur papenda
ministre de l'éducation nationale et de
la jeunesse merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés madame
la députée Nadia permettez-moi de
m'associer à la justesse de vos mots et
de vos pensées en hommage à Samuel Paty
le mage qui s'est tenu
le match qui s'est tenu dans toutes les
écoles et établissements de France
vendredi et lundi en sa mémoire témoigne
de l'engagement des élèves et des
professeurs qui ont commémoré cet acte
barbare pour éveiller et enseigner la
liberté d'expression et la possibilité
même dans saigner je tiens à saluer
l'engagement de tous les professeurs qui
ont contribué à faire de cet hommage un
moment de recueillement et de réflexion
cet hommage aura lieu chaque année
l'enseignement moral et civique sera
poursuivi et je souhaite qu'il soit
renforcé dans le cadre de la
transformation du collège bien sûr pour
transmettre les valeurs de la République
mais aussi pour développer chez tous les
élèves la capacité à s'engager à
analyser à comprendre et à se forger un
avis plus largement tout au long du
parcours scolaire l'enseignement de
l'histoire-géographie de l'enseignement
aux médias et à la philosophie contribue
à comprendre le monde et donne à chacun
la possibilité de s'inscrire dans les
valeurs qui fédèrent notre pays je pense
aussi au service national universel qui
permet de susciter chez les jeunes un
intérêt et un engagement fondé sur
l'esprit collectif l'intérêt général et
la cohésion nationale avec Sébastien
Lecornu et Sarah el Aeri nous avons et
nous travaillons à l'évolution de ce
dispositif enfin je sais aussi pouvoir
compter sur l'ensemble des professeurs
dont les initiatives quotidiennes
permettent de faire vivre les valeurs de
la République vous en avez cité il y en
a beaucoup par exemple le concours
Samuel Paty organisé à l'initiative de
l'association des professeurs
d'histoire-géographie qui en est
l'incarnation et je m'engage à
poursuivre et à soutenir ces projets qui
promouvent nos valeurs au premier rang
desquels la laïcité qui font notre école
merci Monsieur le mesnet la parole est à
Monsieur Jean-Claude Rault pour le
groupe écologiste
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse également à monsieur le
ministre de l'éducation nationale
souvent inaudible déconsidéré par un
pauvres de l'éducation j'espère que pour
une fois vous les entendez à deux rues
d'ici élève enseignante et enseignants
de la voie professionnelle qui battent
le pavé cet après-midi car
urgence il y a
urgence face à une réforme engagée à bas
bruit sous les précédents quinquennat et
qui marque aujourd'hui une rupture
historique avec la principale mission de
l'éducation nationale celle de l'égalité
des chances
j'ai connu de l'intérieur le lycée
professionnel il jouait alors son rôle
d'école de la seconde chance pour des
élèves qui avaient besoin de plus de
temps de plus de confiance et de plus de
considération et cela grâce à des
professeurs profondément investis
c'était pour ces élèves une véritable
opportunité de renouer avec l'école
c'était pour ses enseignants un
véritable choix avec ces ingrédients
réunis j'ai vu de belles et nombreuses
réussites
à mesure que le volume d'heures
d'enseignement généraux diminue c'est
l'entreprise qui prend les commandes des
cursus et laisse à penser à toute une
partie de notre jeunesse qu'elle ne
détient plus les rênes de son avenir
irons-nous vers deux catégories d'élèves
les éclairés qui seront au lycée général
et technologique et les exécutants à
moindre coût malléable selon les besoins
des entreprises
après avoir été l'école de la seconde
chance pour les élèves issus des classes
défavorisées majoritaires dans cette
filière le lycée professionnel est-il
voué à devenir l'école de la seconde
peine alors ma question est la suivante
comptez-vous encore et décidément si
bien votre marque de fabrique faire
passer cette réforme en force réforme à
laquelle toute la voie professionnelle
professionnelle est opposée je vous
remercie la parole est à madame Carole
Grandjean ministre délégué chargé de
l'enseignement et de la formation
professionnelle merci madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés monsieur le députéro pour la
première fois un président de la
République porte la voie professionnelle
comme une priorité d'action pour
l'avenir du pays
cette première fois est portée par une
ambition ainsi que celle de la première
ministre qui est de faire des lycées
professionnels une voix de réussite et
d'insertion pour tous nos élèves
des changements des conduites de
d'évolution de la voie professionnelle
ont été déployées sous le précédent
mandat vous l'avez rappelé monsieur le
député dans un contexte difficile de
crise sanitaire et je tiens à saluer ici
le travail des équipes dans les
établissements pour porter cette
transformation
mais nous le savons toutes et tous ici
les fragilités des élèves de lycée
professionnel sont encore trop fortes et
nous devons aller plus loin c'est tout
l'engagement de la promesse républicaine
que vous évoquiez il y a quelques
instants nous devons effectivement
organiser le temps la confiance la
considération de ces élèves ainsi que
des équipes pédagogiques qui les
entourent nous devons donc agir
collectivement dans l'intérêt des jeunes
et porter des objectifs ambitieux celui
de réduire le nombre de décrocheurs
celui de favoriser l'insertion
professionnelle celui de favoriser la
réussite en cas de poursuite d'études je
rappelle qu'un tiers des lycéens passe
par la voix professionnelle et qu'il
nous est nécessaire avec Monsieur le
Ministre papendi de faire réussir tous
les jeunes c'est actuellement pas la
réalité un élève sur deux au sortir de
leur diplôme réussi à s'insérer
professionnellement nous construisons
cette réforme avec les acteurs concernés
et nous installerons très
progressivement cette réforme
j'installerai des groupes dès vendredi
dans ce sens pour que puis nous
puissions travailler tous ensemble dans
un contexte de discussion pour porter
ensemble cette transformation ne pas
s'adapter aux évolutions c'est condamner
ces jeunes à la disqualification et à
l'échec tous ensemble nous devons porter
cette réforme je vous remercie
allez-y mon cher collègues madame la
ministre j'ai en tête les propos tenus
ici même par madame la Première ministre
et ses promesses de République de
l'égalité des chances or le modèle que
vous entendez instaurer mettant danger
l'avenir d'une partie de notre jeunesse
en même temps qu'il libérise et qui
l'enferme au lieu de l'émanciper
la parole
est un monsieur Davy Rayman du groupe
GDR
[Applaudissements]
emprisonnement et déportation font
partie faire partie faire partie de
notre histoire car définir
allez s'il vous plaît allez-y mon cher
collègue continuez
[Musique]
de notre histoire car dévier l'État avec
raison vous êtes interdit
plus récemment qu'agrélistes du RTE
jeudi que c'est mon histoire par la
vôtre il faut bien écouter les gars ok
plus récemment 4 greffes du R2 se sont
retrouvés en garde à vue 96 heures à la
DGSI depuis qu'on applique-t-on des
outils antiterroriste contre des
militants quand cesserez-vous cette
spirale sécuritaire et liberté site qui
retourne les outils antiterroriste
contre des ports entiers de la société
certains parmi nous ont remis en cause
la désobéissance civile pas plus tard
hier avant-hier soir et aujourd'hui je
ferai quelques rappels historique chers
amis
le militantisme et la désobéissance
civile en milieu le peuple français à
battre une monarchie pour ériger une
démocratie et ce en coupant les têtes de
leur souverain la désobéissance civile a
permis aux miens que je me tienne debout
devant vous s'enchaînent au panier et
son boulet au pied monsieur le ministre
quand nous la démocratie
le militantisme et le droit de grève
[Musique]
je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Gérald Darmanin
ministre de l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer
[Applaudissements]
le président de Monsieur les députés
monsieur député peut-être que vous
propose sont légèrement excessifs
et sans doute qu'une partie des mots que
vous utilisez qui sont particulièrement
blessants pour une grande partie de nos
compatriotes ont dépassé votre pensée
et puisque nous parlons de l'histoire
moi je m'engueille faire partie d'un
gouvernement républicain de se dire que
celui qui a aboli ce que vous évoquez
ici et ce que nous pouvons tous ici nous
réjouir c'est que nous sommes tous des
élus républicains monsieur le député
qu'il n'y a pas d'un côté de l'autre ce
qui serait pour ou contre un système qui
serait autoritariste auquel respecterait
pas les droits de l'homme nous sommes
tous des fils des lumières et les filles
des lumières et nous sommes tous des
républicains
et par ailleurs monsieur député puisque
vous évoquez des rappels historiques je
me permettrais de vous dire puisque vous
faites partie du corps législatif que
nous appliquons les lois de la
République dans l'exécutif et que s'il
vous souhaitez les changer il vous
appartient peut-être de pouvoir proposer
ces changements pour que vos pères
puissent les adopter deuxièmement
monsieur député je veux dire que le
ministère d'intérieur et les services de
police et de gendarmerie appliquent ce
que l'autorité judiciaire lui demande
d'appliquer et lorsque des gens sont mis
en garde à vue lorsqu'ils sont mis en
prison lorsqu'ils sont connus par la
justice ils sont mis et condamnés par la
justice en prison sont les lois de la
République et sont les règles d'un état
de droit et Monsieur le Député je crois
que indépendamment des difficultés que
vous évoquez jetez le prof avec des mots
particulièrement malheureux ne rend pas
service à la République et créer une
confusion sans doute malheureuse parce
que j'espère qu'elle n'est pas dans
votre esprit pour encore recréer
davantage de violence
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
vous avez 6 secondes mon cher collègue
[Applaudissements]
juste pour préciser le ministre que dans
mon histoire particulière d'outre-mer ce
que je vous ai dit ça c'est vraiment
passé j'en ai fini je vous remercie
la parole est à Madame anaïve le meurt
pour le groupe Renaissance
merci madame la Présidente
ma question s'adresse à Madame Olivia
Grégoire ministre délégué chargé des TPE
PME du Commerce de l'Artisanat et du
Tourisme je reviens à court week-end en
circonscription et je voulais faire
perdre des questions des interrogations
des entreprises
suis-je éligible aux aides quelles en
sont les critères qu'est-ce que le tarif
réglementé de vente et est-ce que ça
concerne mon entreprise j'ai rencontré
des patrons de PME qui se voient
proposer des offres d'énergie ils ne
savent pas comment y répondre ces
propositions étant soumises à une
réponse quasi immédiate de l'ordre de
quelques heures ils se sentent sous
pression devant faire un choix rapide
des boulangers sont inquiets car il
aurait proposé des tarifs très élevés
avec des augmentations de 200% parfois
même de 500% des menuisiers qui
s'inquiètent de la hausse des prix de
l'énergie sur la réactivité et le report
de celle-ci auprès de leurs clients
voici les questions qui reviennent le
plus souvent de la part des entreprises
face à l'augmentation du prix de
l'énergie contrairement à ce que l'on
peut entendre sur ces bancs ces chefs
d'entreprise qui voient leur facture
augmenter ça aussi que le gouvernement
agit seulement parce que l'information
ne vient pas forcément à eux ils pensent
souvent être écartés des dispositifs mis
en place
jusqu'ici les prix de l'énergie étaient
encore bas et ne représentait pas un
sujet d'inquiétude particulier pour
nombre d'entrepreneurs les possibilités
qui existaient n'étaient pas leurs
préoccupations première et aujourd'hui
beaucoup d'entre eux se sentent seuls et
désarmés face à une situation qui peut
avoir de lourdes conséquences pour leur
avenir il y a sur ce sujet un véritable
travail de pédagogie à mener en
particulier auprès des petits et
moyennes entreprises madame la ministre
ces entreprises sont parfois perdues
simplement parce que les bonnes
informations ne ne revienne pas aussi ma
demande est aussi claire comment
comptez-vous adresser vous adresser à
ses publics pour qu'il n'y ait pas le
sentiment d'être abandonné je vous
remercie je vous remercie la parole est
à Madame Olivia Grégoire ministre
délégué chargé des petites et moyennes
entreprises du commerce de l'artisanat
et du tourisme merci
madame la présidente madame la députée
le meurt oui la situation elle est
complexe et c'est normal qu'un certain
nombre de nos petits entrepreneurs
notamment et parfois du mal à se repérer
dans les dispositifs d'aide que le
ministre de l'Économie Bruno Le Maire et
ses équipes sont en train de déployer on
est au travail d'arrache-pied vous le
savez notamment au niveau européen pour
faire bouger les lignes alors je vais
avoir une réponse très pragmatique pour
répondre à votre question très
simplement quoi comment vous êtes une
TPE de moins de 10 salariés je pense au
menuisier au boulanger dont vous venez
de mentionner vous êtes éligible
effectivement au TRV TPE tarif
réglementé de vente moins de 2 millions
d'euros de chiffre d'affaires moins de
10 salariés et une puissance
d'électricité jusqu'à 36 kg a couvre
aujourd'hui 1,5 millions de not TPE qui
sont couverts au niveau du bouclier
tarifaire comme les ménages comme enjam
bénéficie on contacte son fournisseur
d'énergie je suis un boulanger et en
règle générale j'ai bien plus de
consommation que 36 kg vol a
parler avec ce matin je les reçois je
vous entends je les écoute aux côtés de
Bruno Le Maire nous sommes en train de
travailler parce qu'il ne rentre pas
dans les cases alors qu'est-ce qu'on est
en train de faire on change les cases
nous sommes en train de me donner la
bataille au plan européen pour faire en
sorte que les critères d'aide pour les
TPE et les PME changent comment faire en
sorte que les aides directes d'État
soient activés à partir du moment où les
dépenses d'énergie représentent 3% de
leur chiffre d'affaires non pas par
rapport à 2021 mais par rapport au mois
de 2022 où il demande les aides c'est un
changement majeur ça va nous permettre
de faire entrer nos boulangers nos
menuisiers nos bouchers qui ont la
chaîne du froid nos artisans vont être
protégés nous les avons accompagnés
pendant le covid jamais nous ne les
redécerons tomber pour en bénéficiaire à
compter du mois de novembre début
novembre sur le site impop.gouv.fr ils
pourront s'inscrire et bénéficier de
cette aide pour tous les autres qui
n'ont pas de contrat pour ceux à qui on
offre des contrats mirobolants pour ceux
qui n'ont pas le temps de répondre parce
travail précieuses pour répondre le
médiateur des entreprises fait un
travail formidable il est activable il
est activé contactez le je vous remercie
merci Madame la Ministre la parole est à
Monsieur Paul Vanier
nationale vous préparez la destruction
du lycée professionnel
voie d'émancipation pour 627 000 jeunes
un tiers des lycéens du pays
majoritairement issus des catégories
populaires je résume votre intention le
remplacement des cours par des stages
des professeurs par des patrons de la
voie professionnelle par le tout
apprentissage
vous vous apprêtez à diminuer d'un tiers
les heures de français de mathématiques
d'histoire et de langue comme si la
jeunesse populaire n'avait besoin ni de
savoir ni de culture à diminuer les
heures d'enseignement professionnel
comme si la transition de notre modèle
productif n'exigez pas l'élévation du
niveau de qualification des élèves vous
poursuivez une triste finalité comptable
la suppression de 8 à 10 000 postes
d'enseignants et déjà on annonce en
Île-de-France la fermeture de plusieurs
établissements surtout vous renoncez à
la mission éducative du lycée
professionnel pour la déléguer au
patronat pour vous les lycéens
professionnels ne sont qu'une main
d'oeuvre si possible gratuite
seul compte la satisfaction des besoins
locaux des entreprises raison pour
laquelle vous souhaitez soumettre à
leurs exigences la carte des formations
et disloquer tout cadrage national pour
nous
les lycéens et lycéens de la voie
professionnelle sont les ouvriers
spécialisés les techniciens et
l'ingénieurs de demain
indispensables à la bifurcation
écologique du pays à la
réindustrialisation de notre économie
leurs besoins de qualification
grandissent avec la complexité
croissante des métiers monsieur le
ministre une inter syndicale unanime
rejette votre projet de réforme les
enseignants et les lycéens suivent
aujourd'hui une grève massive allez-vous
donc renoncer à votre projet de sa cage
je vous remercie la parole est à madame
Carole Grandjean ministre délégué chargé
de l'enseignement et de la formation
professionnelle merci madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés monsieur le député Vanier vous
prêtez des intentions au gouvernement
qui sont tout à fait inexactes vous n'y
est la réalité celle des difficultés des
lycées professionnels par des raccourcis
et des discours anxiogènes parfaitement
inutiles dans un contexte qui nous veut
au contraire être constructif vous dites
qu'il y aura moi d'enseignement c'est
faux vous nous prêtez une démarche court
termiste c'est faux c'est tout l'inverse
qui est en train effectivement d'être
préparé celle des compétences de nos
jeunes pour préparer durablement leur
avenir notre seul objectif c'est la
réussite des jeunes
le constat qui n'a rien de nouveau c'est
étalement et il n'ayant rien lié à
l'engagement formidable des professeurs
qui font un travail remarquable au
quotidien avec deux tiers des
décrocheurs qui sortent de la voie
professionnelle avec seulement la moitié
des diplômés qui sont insérés dans
l'emploi avec un mâchelier sur deux qui
obtient son diplôme quand il poursuit
ses études cela nous oblige
collectivement à agir alors nous avons
peut-être un point commun qui est celui
de dire que nos enfants doivent pouvoir
effectivement trouver une place dans la
société mais nous avons un désaccord
profonds qui est celui de dire que la
voix professionnelle pour nous elle doit
être professionnalisante ouvrir des
opportunités le fond du problème je vous
le dire ce qu'il est c'est que vous
remettez en question le modèle de la
voix professionnelle à la française
c'est à dire une formation qui fait à la
fois qui se fait à la fois à l'école et
par le biais de période de formation
d'entreprise les jeunes et leurs
familles c'est ce à quoi elles aspirent
que nous dordognons l'opportunité
d'avoir des parcours professionnels et
des réussites personnelles
vous critiquez d'ailleurs une réforme
que vous ne connaissez même pas pourquoi
vous ne la connaissez pas parce que vous
vous ne passerez pas encore écrite cette
réforme elle va consister à investir en
lit ces professionnels comme jamais nous
l'avons fait jusqu'à présent par la
formation des professeurs par les
formations d'avenir par la gratification
des élèves lors des périodes de stage
par l'intensification de
l'accompagnement et le renforcement des
enseignements généraux alors vous voyez
effectivement nous sommes en profond
désaccord ça investissement dans
l'avenir de nos enfants par le dialogue
social nous la construirons avec les
parties prenantes merci
il vous reste trois secondes
monsieur le ministre de l'Éducation
votre refus de répondre et la marque de
votre profond mépris pour le Lycée
professionnel
la parole est à Monsieur David topiac
pour le groupe liberté
indépendante outre-mer et territoires
merci madame la Présidente
ma question s'adresse au ministre de
l'éducation nationale et de la jeunesse
monsieur le ministre c'est un sentiment
d'inquiétude de colère qui se manifeste
aujourd'hui dans l'enseignement
professionnel face à votre futur réforme
principalement cause l'augmentation de
plus de 50% de la durée des stages en
entreprise lorsque l'on connaît les
difficultés pour les trouver
la diminution mécanique des orcles sacs
à l'enseignement général avec une
interrogation sur l'avenir des
enseignants et enfin calibrage de
l'offre d'enseignement sur les besoins à
recrutement du territoire
une réforme de la voie professionnelle
est certes nécessaire au regard de ces
difficultés
milliards vos propositions tous les
ferments d'une inégalité de traitement
envers des territoires et des élèves
issus très majoritairement de classes
populaires
en plaçant l'enseignement professionnel
sous le double égide du des ministères
de l'Éducation nationale et du travail
vous renvoyez la formation de ces
enfants une logique d'orientation
réduite au profit de l'environnement
économique local
de plus la marge de progression de
l'apprentissage pour le public des
lycées professionnels et limités car ces
élèves se sont trop jeunes pour intégrer
des entreprises qui en recrutent je
rappelle que 70% des élèves de Seconde
professionnelle soit
âgé de 15 ans et moins une autre voie de
réforme est pourtant possible qui
nécessite au contraire redonner à la
voie professionnelle et les heures
d'enseignants qui ont été retirés au fil
des années ses lycée une meilleure
réussite aux examens informations
initiales des poursuites d'études plus
nombreuses et un taux de décrochage au
moins élevé monsieur le ministre il fut
un autre siècle considéré que
l'émancipation des enfants de 15 ans
n'était pas le travail mais devait se
faire parler l'apprentissage des savoirs
une bonne réforme ne s'impose pas le
convaincre
allez vous revoir une copie déjà si mal
engagée
je vous remercie la parole est à madame
Carole Grandjean ministre délégué chargé
de l'enseignement et de la formation
professionnelle merci madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés monsieur le député topiac
l'objectif de cette réforme il est il
est très clair il est de donner toutes
les chances à nos enfants la voie
professionnelle elle représente un tiers
des lycéens dans effectivement dans
l'orientation qui est prise ce tiers de
lycéen pourtant nous observons un
résultat finalement qui est
pragmatique qui est celui que un élève
sur deux qui est diplômé ne parvient pas
à s'insérer dans l'emploi ce constat il
nous oblige il oblige effectivement une
responsabilité collective une
responsabilité pour agir pour leur
donner toutes les chances de réussir et
de permettre cette relation et que
l'entreprise qui leur permet de cette
professionnalisation mais aussi cet
engagement sur les savoirs fondamentaux
que le Président de la République a
porté à nouveau aux Sables-d'Olonne le
13 septembre dernier je lance ce
vendredi d'autres groupes de travail ces
quatre groupes de travail avec
l'ensemble des parties prenantes vise à
répondre à quatre défis celui de la
réduction du nombre de décrocheurs et ça
aussi ça nous oblige deux tiers des
décrocheurs sont tissus de la voie
professionnelle nous aurons aussi
également un travail sur l'insertion
professionnelle et comment nous
réussissons ce défi de l'insertion
professionnelle nous aurons également un
défi sur la poursuite d'études car trop
d'élèves qui poursuivent des études ne
réussissent pas à obtenir leur diplôme
et puis nous donnerons des capacités au
chef d'établissement pour agir dans leur
projet d'établissement pour réussir tout
en conservant le caractère national des
diplômes à porter des projets
territoires et favoriser la réussite de
ces élèves alors effectivement tous
ensemble nous allons porter des
réflexions avec les organisations
syndicales avec les personnels de
l'éducation avec les acteurs économiques
avec les parents d'élèves avec les
représentants des élèves nous allons
effectivement trouver les moyens de
faire réussir ses élèves et donner la
capacité aux enseignants de faciliter
leur mission le président de la
République la première ministre monsieur
le ministre et moi-même nous portons
avec les acteurs cette réforme sans
qu'elle soit préalablement rédigée sans
qu'elle soit demain déployée de manière
uniforme en tout et partout donc
véritablement monsieur le député croyez
en notre capacité de travail collectif
merci beaucoup vous avez deux secondes
mon cher collègue oui je ne suis pas
convaincu je demande à l'être et être
associé à ces groupes de travail merci
merci beaucoup pour le
[Musique]
groupe merci
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de la
transition écologique et de la cohésion
des territoires le vendredi 14 octobre
lors de la huitième journée nationale de
la qualité de l'air votre ministère a
publié le bilan de la qualité de l'air
extérieur en France pour l'année 2021
qui confirme son amélioration dans notre
pays et nous nous en réjouissons
évidemment tous en effet les émissions
ainsi que les concentrations moyennes
annuelles des principaux polluants sont
en baisse grâce à la mise en oeuvre de
stratégies de plan d'action par le
gouvernement sous le quinquennat
précédent et ce dans plusieurs secteurs
énergétiques agricole transport
notamment avec les aides F e m toutefois
certains dépassements persistent dans
plusieurs de nos territoires
particulièrement lors de pics de
pollution
le Conseil d'État a d'ailleurs condamné
l'État à payer une astreinte de 30
millions d'euros pour les trois derniers
semestres observant que les seuils
limites restaient dépassés dans 5 zones
la qualité de l'air est un enjeu
environnemental et de santé publique qui
nous concerne tous les pics de pollution
ne sont plus malheureusement
conscrits aux grandes métropoles ou
agglomérations les habitants des
communes plus rurales sont désormais
également victimes nous devons donc
poursuivre tous ensemble nos efforts
afin de vrai à une meilleure qualité de
l'air
aussi Monsieur le Ministre quelle mesure
forte allez vous prendre en concertation
avec les acteurs des territoires dans
les prochains mois afin que les seuils
limitent de pollution
soient bien respectées je vous remercie
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Christophe béchum ministre de
la transition écologique et de la
cohésion des territoires
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre madame la députée le NF
vous l'avez dit
nous avons priacte de la décision du
Conseil d'État de prononcer deux
nouvelles astreintes de 10 millions
d'euros qui s'ajoutent à la précédente
de l'année dernière
mais je veux aller au fond de ce que le
Conseil d'État a dit c'est qu'il
constate dans le même temps
des améliorations sur cette qualité de
l'air et quand on regarde sur un temps
plus long on s'aperçoit que nous avions
très zones en France qui était dans
dépassement 2017 c'était déjà une
décision du Conseil d'État que ce
chiffre était tombé à 8 en 2020 qu'il
était de 5 en 2021 et qu'il est de 3
avec 2 en limite de dépassement pour
l'année 2021 achevé
Paris Lyon et Marseille pour autant le
sujet c'est pas le nom de territoire
c'est le nombre de décès qui sont liés à
la médiocre qualité de l'air plus de 40
000 décès dans notre pays sont
directement reliés à cette médiocre
qualité de l'air un des leviers ce sont
les zones affaiblissement je sais que
malgré leur vote dans le cadre de la loi
climat est résilience certains avant
même leur mise en oeuvre discutent de
leurs bien-fondé dès la semaine
prochaine avec Clément bonne nous
recevrons les maires de toutes les
villes de plus de 150 000 habitants et
les présidents des intercommunalités
ceux qui ont déjà mis en place les aides
ce qui s'apprête à le faire pour
discuter des moyens pour les accompagner
il y aura des crédits dans le cadre du
notamment du fond vert c'est le plan
vélo c'est les primes mais il y a aussi
un travail d'harmonisation et
d'acceptabilité sociale à développer et
de ce point de vue je veux saluer le
rapport rendu par les deux députés
millièmes et le seul qui ouvre un
certain nombre de pistes et qui de
manière transpartisane donne des
conseils au gouvernement sur la manière
d'avancer ça inspirera nos travaux pour
que nous puissions revenir vers vous et
mesurer ensemble le chemin qui nous
reste à parcourir je vous remercie
monsieur le ministre la parole est à
monsieur Jean-Jacques Gauthier pour les
républicains
je voudrais associer à ma question mes
collègues Nicolas et députés de l'Allier
de Vichy ou monsieur Fabrice brun député
de l'Ardèche et étend d'autres sur tous
les bancs ma question s'adresse à
Monsieur le Ministre de la santé et de
la prévention et concerne le
remboursement des cures thermales par
l'Assurance Maladie actuellement les
cures thermales sont remboursés à 65%
sur prescription médicale et représente
0,15% des dépenses de l'assurance
maladie la convention qui lit nos
établissements thermaux et l'assurance
maladie arrive à échéance à la fin de
l'année et une nouvelle convention est
actuellement en cours de négociation
pour entrer en vigueur au 1er janvier
2023 or certains ici même évoquent un
éventuel déremboursements et remettant
cause l'efficacité même des cures
thermales il y aurait là un triple
risque un risque économique avec 600 000
curistes sur la France entière et 500
millions d'euros de chiffre d'affaires
pour une centaine de stations un risque
territorial puisque 70% de ces stations
ont moins de 5000 habitants et sont
situés dans les territoires ruraux des
territoires ruraux déjà fragilisés après
deux ans de covid et puis un risque pour
nos patients sécurisent se soigne avec
un service médical rendu évalué
notamment avec les experts désignés par
votre ministère et l'Agence française
pour la recherche thermale avec des
diminutions de journées
d'hospitalisation des diminutions de
consommation médicamenteuses alors
monsieur le ministre pour nos patients
pour nos territoires et de vous
favorables au maintien du remboursement
des cures thermales
je vous remercie la parole est à Madame
Agnès Firma le Bodo ministre délégué
chargé de l'organisation territoriale et
des professions de santé madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés monsieur le député Jean-Jacques
Gauthier vous m'interrogez sous
l'opportunité du remboursement des cures
thermales la France compte 770 sources
d'eau thermale dont 400 sont exploitées
pour leur vertu thérapeutiques reconnues
par l'Académie de médecine à maintenant
vous l'avez un amendement comme vous
l'avez évoqué a été adopté par la
commission des affaires sociales prévoit
non par d'empêcher tout remboursement
des cures thermales mais de les
conditionner à une démonstration
d'effets scientifique prouvé après avis
de la Haute Autorité de Santé le
thermalisme est très important
pour de nombreux territoires vous l'avez
souligné et l'association à votre
question de nombreux députés le prouve
d'ailleurs il y a 110 établissements
thermaux en France dans environ 11
régions je vais pas toutes les citer
parce que je vais en oublier certaines
il y a un secteur qui a particulièrement
souffert de la crise du covid-19 puisque
près de une chute de près de 40 % des
thermalistes a été
constatés le gouvernement est
particulièrement attentif à ce secteur
qui vous l'avez rappelé l'avait rappelé
emploi trois beaucoup de salariés et
agit dans trois secteurs et continuera à
le soutenir et je ne doute pas que les
débats qui nous attendent le cadre du
PLFSS permettront des échanges de
qualité
je vous remercie madame la ministre
allez-y mon cher collègue
parce que la prévention est au cœur du
thermalisme le ministre de la santé et
de la prévention doit soutenir le
thermalisme parce que la banque des
territoires la Caisse des Dépôts l'État
les régions les départements les
communes soutiennent et investissent
fortement dans le thermalisme comme dans
les Vosges par exemple le gouvernement
dans son entier doit soutenir le
thermalisme je vous remercie la parole
est à Monsieur Michael boulot pour le
groupe socialiste
[Applaudissements]
madame la Première ministre hier à Paris
Lyon Clermont-Ferrand Rennes Grenoble
Strasbourg en Seine-Saint-Denis et
ailleurs en France 2000 enfants ont
dormi dehors à la rue et les mots du
président de la République en 2017
résonne cruellement aujourd'hui je ne
veux plus avait-il dit d'ici la fin de
l'année voir des femmes et des hommes
dans la rue dans les bois ou perdus
c'est une question de dignité
5 ans après c'est un drame qui se joue
encore et encore au quotidien sous nos
yeux et avec des conséquences terribles
pour les enfants
notre pays pourtant signataire de la
Convention internationale des droits de
l'enfant se met quotidiennement en
situation d'illégalité en laissant
chaque soir ces 2000 enfants sans
logement
l'hébergement d'urgence relève en effet
des compétences de l'État mais où est
l'état
arène ville de ma circonscription la
municipalité tente de pallier la
non-réponse de l'État hors de ses
compétences et à ses propres frais mais
il reste des dizaines d'enfants à la rue
qui attendent l'action de l'État
avec plusieurs collègues députés dont
une députée de votre majorité nous avons
signé une tribune initiée par la
Fondation Abbé Pierre qui appelle à
mettre fin aux scandale des enfants à la
rue je vous invite toutes et tous à la
découverte
les collectivités territoriales et le
monde associatif sont les rustines d'un
État défaillant qui de surcroît prévoit
de supprimer 14000 places d'hébergement
d'urgence dans le projet de loi de
finances pour 2023
madame la Première ministre il faut agir
immédiatement quelles actions
comptez-vous prendre et allez vous
remettre les 14 000 places d'hébergement
d'urgence dans le projet de loi de
finances le groupe des députés
socialistes et apparentés à déposer
plusieurs amendements ce sens allez vous
les accepter merci
je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Olivier Klein
ministre délégué chargé de la ville et
du logement
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
boulot vous avez raison la
question des enfants à la rue et sans
domicile est une situation insupportable
que nous n'acceptons pas plus que vous
je voudrais d'abord vous dire je
voudrais d'abord vous dire que la
situation de ces enfants n'est pas due à
une reprise par exemple des expulsions
locatives elle n'est pas du non plus à
la baisse de l'hébergement d'urgence
puisque hier soir encore il y avait 197
500 places d'hébergement d'urgence dans
notre pays soit plus de 60 000 places
supplémentaires qu'en 2017 j'avais un
effort a été fait de manière aussi
importante pour l'hébergement d'urgence
depuis de nombreuses années
je voudrais vous dire puisque cette
situation est absolument insupportable
que dès demain matin avec la secrétaire
des tâches Charlotte cobel nous
recevrons à nouveau les associations
porteurs de cette situation pour essayer
de trouver une solution avec pour
chacune de ces enfants association que
nous avions déjà vu à la rentrée
scolaire et auquel nous avions demandé
qu'elle nous signale l'ensemble de ces
cas j'ai aussi demandé à nouveau au
préfet de faire un recensement des
différents cas connus pour que nous
trouvions une solution pour ses enfants
sur leur territoire et aussi à sur
l'ensemble du territoire national car
vous le savez cette situation ne peut
pas se régler à l'échelle des grandes
métropoles mais doit se régler sur
l'échelle de l'ensemble de notre
territoire enfin je vais vous le dire
notre priorité comme la vôtre c'est le
passage de la rue au logement à travers
le logement d'abord et nous continuerons
avec le gouvernement apporter ce
dispositif extrêmement important qui
nous permettra de continuer à lutter
contre la très grande précarité je vous
remercie je vous remercie
là il vous reste 5 secondes il y a
urgence merci d'agir je vous remercie et
enfin Monsieur Stéphane Rambaud pour le
rassemblement national
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre de l'Intérieur
fort de mes 37 années passées en tant
que commissaire de police dans huit
départements aux problématiques variées
donc avec cette expérience au coeur même
de l'institution policière et
aujourd'hui député du Var au regard de
ce que j'entends je peux vous dire que
le malaise dans la police est profond
votre projet qui sous prétexte de
décloisonnement vise à placer tous les
services y compris ceux de la police
judiciaire sous les ordres d'un
directeur départemental unique dépendant
du préfet inquiète les policiers mais
aussi les professionnels de justice
magistrates et avocats la conférence des
procureurs généraux c'est d'ailleurs
prononcé officiellement pour une
suspension de votre réforme
votre directeur général Frédéric vaut
auditionner à l'Assemblée il y a deux
semaines justifiez votre réforme qui
disait rendu nécessaire du fait de la
complexité de la procédure pénale mais
alors c'est bien cette procédure pénale
qu'il faudrait simplifier de manière
drastique et urgente vous le savez et
j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de vous le dire
en commission des lois lors de votre
audition le passage d'une organisation
hiérarchique zonale à une organisation
départementale sous tutelle de la
sécurité publique n'est pas adaptée aux
nécessités des enquêtes les plus
sensibles non les policiers ne sont pas
interchangeables c'est ce que tente de
vous dire les officiers de police
judiciaire mais apparemment vous ne les
entendez pas
vouloir s'entêter à imposer votre
réforme serait une faute politique
majeure Georges Clémenceau doit s'en
retourner dans sa tombe ma question est
donc simple allez vous vous enferrer
dans votre volonté de réforme ou
allez-vous vers preuve de sagesse
l'abandonner purement
la parole est à Monsieur Gérald Darmanin
ministre de l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer
madame la Présidente de Monsieur les
députés monsieur le député j'ai eu
l'occasion de dire que la réforme de la
police nationale qui n'est pas que la
réforme de la police judiciaire est
attendu notre pays depuis 35 ans quel
que soit les ministres et quel que soit
les gouvernements d'ailleurs je voudrais
ici vous dire qu'il s'agit pas de mettre
ce tutelle la police judiciaire à la
sécurité publique quoi que avouer avec
moi que les policiers de sécurité
publique sont tout à fait respectables
et le méritent sans doute pas
la distance que vous semblez à incarner
avec eux c'est l'immense majorité des
policiers qui nous protègent je pense
que nous pourrions leur rendre eux ici
hommage plutôt que les voies ogemonies
comme vous le faites ici
je veux ici vous dire que vous ne pouvez
pas non plus relayer les fake news que
vous l'avez fait parce que vous n'aurez
alors pas lu la lettre que j'ai adressée
pourtant publier à l'ensemble des
policiers et que j'écris à monsieur le
garde des sceaux également pour que
chacun puisse l'entendre il n'y a pas
une mesure législative monsieur le
député que je change en faisant la
réforme de la police nationale pas un
seul article de loi que nous changeons
c'est bien la preuve que tout est
réglementaire et donc il n'y a ni
atteinte à l'autorité judiciaire ni
atteinte à la séparation des pouvoirs
qui peut penser à son instant que nous
pourrions remettre en cause ce
fonctionnement de la justice si on ne
devait pas toucher ni le code de
procédure pénale ni le code pénal je
pense qu'il faut que nous soyons sérieux
mais enfin votre intervention m'a permis
de rappeler que le somme évidemment
après les excès professionnelles tout à
fait à l'écoute qu'il ne s'agit pas de
mettre tout le monde dans une direction
départementale bien évidemment
j'aimerais me confirmé les offices et
les antennes régionales qui se
regardaient mais que nous devons
améliorer les choses monsieur député
vous ne pouvez pas ici nous dire que le
taux d'élucidations est trop bas que les
policiers s'arrête pas assez les
délinquants qu'une région pas assez les
violences et refuser lorsque vraiment on
fait des réformes pour cela c'est vrai
qu'il faut être courageux mais j'ai
appris monsieur député deux informations
importantes la première c'est que vous
désormais vous citer Clémenceau je ne
suis pas tout à fait certain qu'il
aurait été content de cela le monde a
changé depuis que les morceaux et la
deuxième Madame Le Pen c'est que vous
citez les procureurs généraux vous ne
avez jamais autant cité avoir du Front
national
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre la
séance des questions gouvernement est
terminée la séance est suspendue